Und man hört es schon an dem etwas anderen Anfang am heutigen Abend, 22 Uhr der Blue Moon, heute wieder Chaosradio, drei Stunden Chaos Computer Club in der Haus und die Vornamen überlasse ich den Herren selbst.
Meiner ist zumindest Max, ich bin Steini, schönen guten Tag und Andreas am Apparat.
Ich nicht san chi. Ich nie san xie.
Puh Im Zellenrein sind immer schon die Besten, das kann man durchaus behaupten, Kraftwerk, die nochmal die musikalische vierminütige Ankündigung sein für den Blue Moon, der heute Abend stattfindet. Chaosradio, drei Stunden lang. Das Thema des heutigen Abends ist Biometrie und an dieser Stelle gebe ich ab an den Chaos Computer Club selbst. Biometrie, Jungs, was ist das überhaupt? Weil ich hab festgestellt, ich hab hier mal einfach gesagt, aus dem Brustton der Überzeugung heraus, hab ich einfach gesagt auf die Frage hin, was macht ihr heute Abend? Hab ich gesagt, naja Biometrie, nicht? Bitte was? Und das ungefähr vier von fünf Mal. Deswegen denke ich, dass für alle Hörer in Berlin und Brandenburg es adäquat wäre, noch mal kurz zum Schreiben, was Biometrie überhaupt ist.
Genau, erstmal schönen Dank, dass das nun losgeht. Lange genug gewartet. Biometrie, das heutige Thema. Um was geht's eigentlich? Viele verstehen unter Biometrie so Sachen wie, ich steck mir ein Fieberthermometer in den Po oder ich guck mal, was im Blut so drin ist. Und das ist auch tatsächlich der eigentliche Ursprung von Biometrie. Das heißt, das Messen von Bio-Funktionen üblicherweise des menschlichen Körpers. Man kann natürlich auch andere biologische Sachen messen, aber im Wesentlichen geht es darum, nämlich den menschlichen Körper zu erforschen und messtechnisch zu ergründen. Da gibt es viele Sachen, die man messen kann. Das fängt mit Blutzuckerspiegel an, Cholesterin und alle möglichen Sachen im Blut. Das fängt damit an, dass man verschiedenste EKG, EEG machen kann und so fort. Und das ist eigentlich auch der Ursprung der Biometrie. Irgendwann kam mal jemand auf die Idee, ob man mit diesen Messmethoden und Verfahren, die es da gibt, nicht auch andere Sachen machen kann.
Wie zum Beispiel Menschen wiederzufinden oder wiederzuerkennen. Und das ist natürlich im Zusammenhang mit den Terroranschlägen jetzt auch, warum das Thema in Deutschland jetzt gerade so hochgekocht wurde, im Rahmen vor allem des sogenannten Otto-Katalogs. Und da spielte auch die Biometrie eine ziemlich wichtige Rolle in diesem Katalog und insbesondere wurde dann auch über Dinge wie Fingerabdrücke und Gesichtserkennung und Speicherung dieser Merkmale im Ausweis viel und kontrovers diskutiert. So die eine Gruppe hält es halt für das große technische Heilmittel, um damit Menschenleben zu retten. Und andere, dazu würde ich mich auch zählen, halten das für eine schlimmere Bedrohung unserer Freiheit und unserer Demokratie als das, was da in Amerika passiert ist.
Wo man ja sagen muss, dass das mit der Biometrie im Ausweis auch nicht ganz neu ist. Schließlich haben wir da alle ein Passbild im Ausweis und das ist ja eigentlich auch bloß ein biometrisches Verfahren, um jemanden wiederzuerkennen. Dann guckt halt der Polizist auf der Straße auf das Foto und dann guckt er einem aufs Gesicht, dann guckt er nochmal aufs Foto und dann guckt er nochmal aufs Gesicht und dann sagt er halt irgendwie, das ist jetzt derselbe oder sagt, das ist nicht derselbe oder sagt, man könnte jetzt mal wieder zum Friseur gehen oder ein neues Foto machen oder was auch immer. Und damit sind wir gleich beim großen Problem von Biometrie. Die Biometrie ist nämlich nie hundertprozentig zuverlässig.
Da könnte ich natürlich als der Ketzer, ich nehme die Rolle für den heutigen Abend einfach mal ein, sagen, ist doch okay, wenn die die Methoden verbessern. Wer stört sich daran, wenn es das ohnehin schon gibt? Warum das nicht auf Fingerabdrücke, Blut, Sperma, genetisches Ketzen?
Naja, das eigentliche Problem ist weniger, das was im Personalausweis oder im alten Personalausweis früher mal drin war, wenn da ein Foto drin klebt oder meinetwegen auch man den Finger auf einen Stempelkissen drückt und seinen Fingerabdruck in den Pass stempelt. Das ist zwar unangenehm und man fühlt sich sicherlich auch nicht so gut dabei, aber das ist noch eingeschränkt gefährlich. Worum es eigentlich geht und wovon die eigentliche Bedrohung ausgeht, ist gar nicht diese biometrischen Merkmale im Personalausweis, sondern dass es eine große Datei gibt, wo diese ganzen Dinge alle drinstehen. Das heißt, mein Fingerabdruck steht dann eben auch in irgendeinem Computer, genauso wie heute mein Bild. Und da sind natürlich die Gefahren riesig, wenn eine solche Datei in falsche Hände gerät. Und so eine Datei weckt natürlich auch überall große Begehrlichkeiten. Und das ist das eigentlich schlimme Problem.
Ja, ich denke, da muss man auch berücksichtigen, dass mit der Einführung von Biometrie durch so was wie den Otto-Katalog, das sollte man vielleicht kurz erklären, mit Otto-Katalog ist nicht der wahren Versandhandel gemeint, sondern der Otto Schily, der gerade dabei ist, im Rahmen dieser Anti-Terror-Allianz in Deutschland Systeme einführen zu wollen, die es ermöglichen, Leute besser zu identifizieren und zu authentifizieren. Das erklären wir gleich noch. Das macht am besten Andreas, der kann das am allercoolsten. Sodass also diese Mechanismen, die da beschrieben werden oder eben auch nicht beschrieben werden, dadurch aber zu einer gewissen Art von Commodity, also zu einer Selbstverständlichkeit werden. Sodass so was wie Biometrie dann halt überall eingeführt und eingesetzt wird, nicht zuletzt, um Gebäude zu betreten, um seinen Computer einzuschalten, um den Fernseher um- oder einzuschalten, auszuschalten um. Und auch das ist in der Diskussion zum Beispiel Waffen nicht abdrücken zu können, wenn da nicht der richtige Finger im Abzug ist und solche Sachen dergleichen mehr.
Ich meine, für diejenigen, die Judge Dredd mochten.
Ja, genau, den habe ich zufällig auch auf Video gesehen. Interessant war auch, dass in dem Film natürlich der Bösewicht genau die biometrischen Merkmale gefälscht hat und damit dann Judge Dredd halt die Todesstrafe eingehandelt hat, weil er nämlich, obwohl die Waffe eben auf den Fingerabdruck und tausend andere biometrische Merkmale codiert war, er durch Manipulation im Rechner halt einen Mord eben dem Judge Dredd anhängt hat, wo du es gerade erwähnt hast.
Es gibt übrigens ungefähr unzählige Filme, in denen Biometrie vorkommt und die auch tatsächlich jedes Mal, und zwar reibungslos umgangen wird. Und das ist auch gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich, aber das kommen wir vielleicht ein bisschen später drauf. Mir war in dem Aspekt eigentlich wichtig zu sagen, wenn sowas überall und immer verfügbar ist, dann fallen damit auch jede Menge Daten an und die sind da nicht nur in dieser einen ganz speziellen staatlichen Datei gespeichert, sondern dann hat zum Beispiel das Unternehmen einen völligen Überblick darüber, wer jetzt tatsächlich alles die Räume betreten hat, dann hat ein Geschäft einen Überblick, wer da eingekauft hat und so weiter.
Jedes Geschäft, was ich betrete, hat dann vielleicht mein Bild in seiner Datei und andere Dinge.
Kurze Frage, ist aber auch okay, weil ich meine, das Geschäft kann natürlich die Regeln aufstellen, dafür unter welchen Bedingungen das Geschäft betreten wird und so.
Oder? Nein, in Deutschland ist es zum Glück alles nicht ganz so einfach, weil es da sowas im Gegensatz zu Amerika schon so etwas wie Datenschutz und ein Selbstbestimmungsrecht und das Recht am eigenen Bild gibt, was dem tatsächlich entgegensteht. Aber es ist natürlich alles nicht sehr einfach zu kontrollieren.
Ja, ich denke, was man da ein bisschen betrachten muss, ist, wenn sich sowas durchsetzt, dann ist die Möglichkeit des Missbrauchs groß. Und da müsste man jetzt tatsächlich mal ein bisschen beleuchten, wo eigentlich das Problem bei der heute üblichen Biometrie ist. Dabei sollten wir ein bisschen genauer anschauen, welche verschiedenen Arten von Biometrie für Identifikation und Authentifizierung gibt es denn überhaupt.
Und ich denke, in die Klassifizierung gehen wir dann nach der Musik.
Ja, dann würde ich dann auch direkt übergangslos so tun, als hätte ich es jetzt sofort verstanden, wende mich zum Rechner, gucke, dass mein Bildschirm schon schnell genug ist, hier wegzuschnippeln.
Das hat ja gut geklappt.
Ja, das hat ja wundervoll geklappt. Und übergangslos gehen wir zu Musik. Die Ehren von Ego Express im Blue Moon auf Fritz und die Ehren vom Chaosradio mir gegenüber um 20 Minuten nach 10. Nochmal einen herzlichen guten Abend. Oder ein herzliches, kann man auch sagen, um einen fröhlichen, wunderschönen guten Morgen. Guten Morgen, um das grammatikalisch richtig zu machen.
Genau. Ja, ich sag dann auch nochmal Hallo und schönen Guten Tag, Herr Steini hier am Apparat.
Und Herr Pawel.
Und der Andreas.
Gut, Biometrie war das Thema und insbesondere durch die biometrischen Systeme, die sich dafür eignen, Menschen zu identifizieren oder zu authentifizieren. Vielleicht Andreas kurz zum Unterschied zwischen identifizieren und authentifizieren.
Der Unterschied ist im Prinzip der, dass man bei der Identifikation automatisch auch rausbekommt, wer das ist. Das heißt, man stellt sich einfach vor eine Kamera und die Kamera sucht dann durch die Datenbank und sagt halt irgendwie, den kenne ich, das ist der Steini oder sagt halt irgendwie, den kenne ich nicht. Und ein Authentifizierungsverfahren ist eins, wo man sagen muss, wer man ist und der Computer überprüft dann, ob das der Wahrheit entspricht. Und es gibt Biometrie-Systeme nach verschiedenen Prinzipien und es gibt halt Prinzipien, die sich zur Identifikation eignen. Es gibt Prinzipien, die sich zur Authentifikation eignen.
Oder von beiden, ja. Grundsätzlich kann man unterscheiden bei biometrischen Systemen danach, welche Art von Merkmalen sie denn messen. Zum einen gibt es diese Klasse von physiologischen Merkmalen, wie den Fingerabdruck, die Iris, das heißt die Struktur, dessen was von außen vom Auge zu sehen ist. Die Messung der Fingerlänge ist ein bekanntes Verfahren.
Nicht nur die Fingerabdrücke selber nehmen, sondern die Fingerlänge messen?
Die Fingerlänge, das heißt die ganze Hand wird. Die Handgeometrie und im Wesentlichen aber die Länge der Finger oder aber auch die Lage der Gelenke.
Ich dachte immer, dass wir nur, wo wir wieder beim Film sind, irgendwas damit man spektakulär erkennt, dass es ein Mensch ist, der seine Foto auf irgendeinen Scanner legt.
Nein, nein, das gibt es auch tatsächlich zu kaufen. Es ist sogar ein Verfahren, was nicht sehr genau ist, was sich allenfalls zur Authentifizierung eignet, aber weniger gut zur Identifizierung, weil eben sehr viele Leute dann doch ähnliche Muster haben. Also man kann nicht jetzt 80 Millionen Menschen anhand ihrer Handstruktur auseinanderhalten. Aber ich gehe vielleicht kurz nochmal die Liste durch. Retina-Muster, also die Struktur der Adern im Augeninneren, also letztendlich auf der Netzhaut, ist so ziemlich das invasivste Verfahren. Da wird dann ins Auge hinein geleuchtet und das Augeninnere gefilmt. Das mögen die wenigsten Leute. Die zweite Klasse neben den physiologischen Merkmalen sind Verhaltensmerkmale. Dazu zählt die Sprache. Anhand der Sprache lässt sich auch jemand ganz gut erkennen. Die Unterschrift, der Gang oder beispielsweise auch der Tipp-Rhythmus auf der Tastatur. Diese Systeme haben alle ihre unterschiedlichen Vor- und Nachteile. Sie sind für viele Dinge geeignet, für manche nicht. Aber sie haben alle eins gemeinsam. Sie sind alle nicht hundertprozentig perfekt. Bei einer Studie, die kürzlich vor wenigen Monaten gemacht wurde, lag je nach System bei einer Stichprobe von etwa 300 Leuten die Rate der falschen Zurückweisungen. Wo das System eigentlich hätte die Person erkennen müssen, bei bis zu 20% beim schlechtesten System. Das heißt, jeder Fünfte wurde fälschlich nicht authentifiziert. Das beste System hatte immerhin noch eine Zurückweisungsrate von 1%. Und das bei einer so kleinen Stichprobe. Dazu muss man auch noch wissen, dass mit der Anzahl der Menschen generell die Systeme auch schlechter werden. Es ist natürlich einfacher, 300 Menschen auseinanderzuhalten als 30 Millionen. Und da in solchen Größenordnungen gibt es eigentlich noch überhaupt keine Erfahrung, wie biometrische Systeme, wie gut die in solch großen Dimensionen eigentlich arbeiten. Ein weiteres Problem, was alle biometrischen Systeme gemeinsam haben, ist oder das liegt einfach in der Natur der Biometrie, die Menschen altern und verändern sich. Das heißt, Grundproblem auch bei allen biometrischen Systemen ist, dass nach einer gewissen Zeit sich die Qualität verschlechtert. Und beispielsweise nach sechs Monaten bereits ist bei den bekannten Systemen die Qualität, also die Rate der falschen Zurückweisung beispielsweise um 400 Prozent gestiegen. Also hat sich vervierfacht nach nur sechs Monaten. Und Langzeiterfahrungen gibt es noch überhaupt nicht. Aber man kann davon ausgehen, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass mich irgendein Biometriesystem nach fünf Jahren wiedererkennt, relativ gering ist nach heutigen Standtechnik bei den meisten Verfahren.
Das ist insofern echt spannend, als dass der Ottokatalog ja vorsieht, dass so etwas an der Grenze gemacht wird. Und der Durchschnittsbürger, der wird die Grenze im Schnitt nicht mehr als alle halbe Jahr mal oder alle Jahre zum Urlaub überschreiten. Und da relativiert sich das tatsächlich so stark, das als Kriterium heranzuziehen und zu sagen, also das ist tatsächlich nicht sehr viel besser als das Foto. Aber beim anderen Aspekt sind die Kombinationen aus den verschiedenen Verfahren erhöht natürlich hier die Sicherheit, gerade bei der Authentifizierung.
Wobei, da ist natürlich die Frage der Machbarkeit sofort auf dem Plan, wenn ich dann an den Flughafen gehen muss und alles muss so derbe gecheckt werden, wie nach dem 11. September, dass jeder mein Gepäck durchsucht und ich muss irgendwie fünf bis sechs Verfahren über mich ergehen lassen. Das schafft doch keiner zeitlich, oder?
Es ist nicht mehr komfortabel, dann irgendwann mal, dass es war.
Naja, es hängt natürlich alles tatsächlich mit der Qualität der Systeme zusammen. Das Schöne ist natürlich, dass jeder Computer heutzutage einfach meistens billiger ist, als einen Menschen da hinzustellen, der dasselbe tut. Nur, wenn die Systeme nicht gut genug sind, dann verursachen sie so viel Ärger und so viel zusätzliche Kosten, indem man dann nicht nur den Menschen, sondern auch noch nicht nur den Computer, sondern den zusätzlichen Menschen, der jetzt den Computer kontrollieren muss, da hinstellt, sodass sich da eigentlich kein Preisvorteil ergibt. Letztendlich ist es fast weniger eine Frage der Sicherheit beim Biometrieeinsatz, sondern eine Frage des Preises, also ob ich billiger kontrollieren kann, als mit den heutigen Methoden, die ich habe, wie Ladendetektive, die ja auch in der Lage sind, Diebe zu identifizieren oder potentielle Diebe an verschiedenen Dingen erkennen.
Was müsste man da so ansetzen, preislich? Man würde nur alle Flughäfen in Deutschland mit so neuen Systemen einrichten.
Da musst du irgendeinen Konsulten fragen.
Stell dir beliebige 2- bis 3-stellige Millionenbeträge vor.
Also das hängt vom System ab. Die Preisspanne liegt am billigsten bei Fingerabdrucksystemen. Die fangen bei einigen 100 Mark an und die teuersten Systeme liegen bei 300-400.000 Mark für Retina-Scanner oder gute Iris-Scanner. Aber da gibt es nur sehr wenig Anbieter. Da ist die Auswahl nicht sehr groß.
Es kommt erschwerend dazu, dass man auch noch ein Datenbank-Backend braucht, auf dem das laufen soll. Und wenn ich mich nicht irre, hat das BKA gerade 120 Millionen dafür verpulvert, InPol neu aufzusetzen, also den Nachfolger der InPol-Datenbank, der zentralen Datenbank aller Bürger der Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Und das funktioniert einfach nicht. Sie kriegen es nicht hin. InPol-Datenbank ist sicherlich dem einen oder anderen schon mal begegnet, der mal angehalten wurde, mit seinem Wagen kontrolliert wurde, keine Papiere dabei hat und sich gewundert hatte, warum die keinen Stress gemacht haben. Das liegt daran, dass da kurz mal in der InPol-Datenbank abgefragt wird, ob dieses Fahrzeug als gestohlen gemeldet ist, auf wen das Fahrzeug registriert ist und wenn dann derjenige, der drin sitzt, auch der Inhaber des Fahrzeugs, sich mit seinem Ausweis ausweisen kann, dann braucht er keinen Führerschein, keine Fahrzeugpapiere dabei zu haben. Das geht alles schon so.
Ist doch perfekt, Fingerabdruck, Retina-Scale, ist alles irrelevant. Man bringt einfach sein Auto mit an zum Flughafen.
Das kann man tun, aber da läuft die Identifizierung ja letzten Endes über das Passbild im Ausweis. Also da ist die Biometrie schon, sagen wir mal, der Schlüsselpunkt bei der ganzen Geschichte. Obwohl man natürlich mit einem Polizisten immer drüber verhandeln kann, ob man diesen Bild jetzt noch ähnlich sieht oder nicht. Ich stelle mir das schwierig vor, wenn man an der Grenze am Drehkreuz ist, diesen 2 x 2 cm Fingerabdruckscanner davon zu überzeugen, dass man jetzt eigentlich doch dadurch möchte.
Gut, da steht natürlich dann trotzdem jemand daneben. Bloß man kann halt mehr Leute durchschleusen. Man muss vielleicht weniger Leute daneben stellen.
Aber wir müssen gleich schon wieder nachrichten. Ich sehe hier mit Schrecken auf die Uhr, dass es gleich halb ist.
Wir haben es dann auch nicht mal umrissen. Ich würde sagen, wir machen gleich weiter investigativ, wie wir sind. Wir lassen erst mal Gerald Kötterheinrich ran, der sich mit seinem Blättchen schon bequem gleich die Nachrichten vorzulesen. 22.30 Uhr.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Mit dem Wetter nachts wolkig und trocken 4 bis 1 Grad. Tag verbreitet Regen dann und 4 bis 7 Grad morgen. Jetzt die Meldungen mit Gerald Kütter-Heinrich.
Die Nordallianz hat offenbar ihren Widerstand gegen eine internationale Friedenstruppe in Afghanistan aufgegeben. Auf der UNO-Konferenz in Bonn hieß es, dass Nordbündnis könne UN-Soldaten akzeptieren, solange diese im Rahmen eines Friedensabkommens stationiert würden. US-Präsident Bush und UN-Generalsekretär Ernan haben ihre Bereitschaft erklärt, der notleidenden Bevölkerung Afghanistans ausreichende Hilfe zukommen zu lassen. Nach einem Gespräch in Washington sagte Bush, es gebe genug Geld und Nahrungsmittel. Die Kernfrage sei aber, wie sie in einem unsicheren Umfeld zu den Menschen gelangten. In Berlin haben sich SPD, Grüne und FDP bei ihren Koalitionsgesprächen auf Einsparungen in den Bereichen Schule und Sport geeinigt. Bei den Punkten Olympia-Bewerbung für 2012 Grundschule und Religion als Wahlpflichtfach erzählten sie jedoch noch keine Verständigung. Ein zweimotoriges Flugzeug ist am Abend in der Nähe von Augsburg verunglückt. Die Polizei vermutet mehrere Tote. Die Maschine befand sich im Anflug auf den Flughafen, als sie aus noch ungeklärter Ursache abstürzte. Zum Fußball der 1. FC Union Berlin hat die nächste Runde des DFB Pokals erreicht. Der Zweitligist siegte beim Verbandsligisten SSV Ulm mit 3 zu 0. Und das Champions League Spiel zwischen Juventus Turin und Bayer Leverkusen ist zum zweiten Mal hintereinander wegen Nebels abgesagt worden. Der Verkehr auf Fritz, eine Meldung A12 Richtung Frankfurt oder zwischen Mühlrose und Frankfurt, Stau vor der Grenze.
Fritz präsentiert ein Konzert nicht nur für Supergirls.
Und das Chaosradio läuft noch. Wir haben es 22.32 Uhr mittlerweile. Wir haben noch zweieinhalb Stunden umzuklären, was Biometrie ist, wie Biometrie funktioniert und wozu sie gut ist und wozu sie eben halt nicht gut ist. Dazu im Studio noch mal vorgestellterweise.
Na, der Steini.
Ja, wir waren gerade noch kurz bei den Kosten. Und da gibt's die Hauptkosten sind vermutlich weniger so sehr die Systeme als wirklich das Ganze drum rum, wenn man das wirklich an den Start bringen will. Man braucht, Andreas erwähnte das schon, das Backend beziehungsweise die Datenbanken. Man muss ziemlich, man kann das Ding nicht einfach von der Stange kaufen und irgendwo aufstellen, sondern muss vorher ziemlich genau recherchieren, was und wie und wo. Dann muss man das irgendwo in eine ganze Umgebung einpassen, die Systemintegration durchführen. Dann die ganze Installation von dem Krempel. Das ist bei biometrischen Systemen auch nicht ganz einfach. Da muss man die ganzen Leute schulen. Dann fallen noch Kosten an für das Versagen der Systeme. Man muss irgendwie mit den Ausnahmen umgehen. Und dann ist es natürlich so, in dem Moment, wo man diese Systeme installiert, werden erst mal auch die Schlangen überall länger. Weil am Anfang wird es erst mal teurer, weil die Sachen nicht so gut funktionieren. Die Abläufe sind andere. Also das kommt alles noch dazu. Das heißt, selbst wenn man wahrscheinlich heute anfängt, das für die gesamte Bundesrepublik, also diese Personalausweisgeschichte zu machen, dann kann man nicht vor Ablauf von, ich würde mal sagen, 20 Jahren mit einem funktionierenden System rechnen.
Gibt es da nicht ein Vorbild? Irgendwie Holland oder meinetwegen Israel. Die wissen ja auch immer alles, wenn man da zum Flughafen kommt. Dass die mal sowas hätten, so eine Datenstruktur, von der man sich was abgucken kann.
Genau deswegen, weil die darauf angewiesen sind, gerade in Israel, dass es funktioniert, machen die das genau nicht. Weil die dort sehen, dass einfach die Mechanismen nicht ausgereift sind und dass das heute keine Technologie ist, auf die man sich verlassen will. Ganz im Gegenteil, die Gefahr ist sehr groß, dass man sich da immer mehr darauf verlässt und dass man sagt, okay, das haben wir jetzt eingeführt, das war teuer genug und nun müssen wir mal sparen und nun werden die Leute, die daneben stehen, langsam wegrationalisiert, immer billiger, genau wie die Leute, die heute die Kästen am Flughafen bedienen, wo da in Gepäck durchleuchtet werden. Die sind immer schlechter ausgebildet und können immer weniger spezielle Dinge entscheiden und erkennen, sodass man sich schon immer mehr auf diese Technik verlässt. Und schlussendlich wird damit die Sicherheit drastisch abnehmen, weil sich dann die Betreiber der Systeme mehr und mehr darauf verlassen, dass das schon gut funktioniert. Und es geht ja auch dann irgendwann vielleicht doch mal schneller. 20 Jahre lass ich mal dahingestellt sein, vielleicht sind es nur 10. Aber die Sicherheit nimmt dadurch ab, dass eben solche biometrischen Systeme eigentlich dafür einen Zugang zu verwehren oder zu erlauben gar nicht besonders gut geeignet sind. Dass es einfach Probleme sind. Oder dass um eine gute Zugangsberechtigung herzustellen, ganz andere Mechanismen nötig wären. Und da können wir jetzt vielleicht mal kurz gegenüberstellen, was man sich eigentlich wünschen würde. Und warum Biometrie, ausgerechnet Biometrie, und ganz vorneweg Fingerprint, dafür wirklich das Gegenteil geeignet sind. Nämlich, dass es totaler Unsinn ist. Und warum das so ist, gucken wir jetzt mal.
Ich denke, das geht schon damit los. Also uns wird ja eingeredet, die Biometrie müsste jetzt eingeführt werden, damit Angriffe wie am 11. September verhindert werden können. Wenn man mal genau guckt, was da passiert ist, ist es so, dass die Leute mit gültigen Pässen, mit ihren eigenen Namen das Flugzeug bestiegen haben. Und ob da jetzt noch ihr Fingerabdruck mit drauf gewesen wäre oder nicht, hätte da einfach keinen Unterschied gemacht. Das heißt, die Grundaussage, wir müssten das jetzt tun, um sowas in Zukunft zu verhindern, ist schon mal völlig falsch. Und auf der anderen Seite schafft man sich plötzlich völlig neue Risiken. Also der Fingeraktro zum Beispiel, der ist ja auch nicht besonders sicher. Wenn man irgendwo in eine Kneipe geht und ein Glas Bier trinkt, dann hat man seine Fingerabdrücke hinterlassen an dem Glas. Und wer weiß, ob da nicht irgendwie im Hinterzimmer das Glas nicht einfach abgewaschen wird, sondern ob da nicht die Fingerabdrücke abgenommen und sorgfältig kopiert werden. Sowas ist ja alles möglich. Man kann, wie man das in Filmen gelegentlich sieht, mit Grafitpulver Fingerabdrücke abnehmen. Kann sie dann zum Beispiel in einen Computer einscannen und auf einen Dia ausbelichten kann, damit eine Mikrolidographie machen. Und kann sich dann im Prinzip einen Gummifinger mit demselben Fingerabdruck machen. Das ist dann möglicherweise eine dünne Silikonschicht, so eine Art Fingerkondom. Man sich dann über den Finger drüber zieht, wo dann der Fingerabdruck von jemand anders drauf ist. Und schon kommt man damit primär überall durch.
Soweit braucht man gar nicht gehen. Im Prinzip genügt auch schon. Steini hat das ausprobiert vor einem Jahr ungefähr. Kannst du vielleicht mal erzählen?
Ich kann die Geschichte erzählen. Damals waren Fingerprint-Systeme gerade am Start. Und alle sagten, hurra, hurra, endlich die Lösung. Ich hab so ein Ding in die Finger gekriegt und gesagt, ich hatte 2, 3 Stück, wir haben auf dem Kongress vor 2 Jahren damit rumgespielt. Ich überlegte, wie machen wir es? Also eine Kerze und ein Zigarettenpapierchen hat gereicht. Wie läuft das? Das ist simpel. Ich hab einfach mal meinen Finger in diesen Kerzenwachs reingedrückt und hab dann mit dem Zigarettenpapierchen und einem Bleistift, nachdem der Wachs hart geworden war, das abgerubbelt. Und weil der dann ja noch Seitenverkehrt ist, hab ich das Zigarettenpapierchen einfach falsch rum. Das ist ja ein bisschen durchsichtig. Auf den Fingerprint-Scanner gehalten. Und Katschung war ich drin. Das war also gar kein Problem in dem Zusammenhang. Das andere System war etwas kniffliger. Das hatte eine sogenannte Lebenderkennung. Weil die Fingerprint-Hersteller, die überlegen sich natürlich auch eine ganze Menge. Da gibt es verschiedene Verfahren, wie man so ein Fingerprint abnimmt. Muss man vielleicht kurz mal erläutern. Da gibt es Systeme, die optisch über eine kleine Kamera, wie sie auch in Webcams drin sind, einfach über den Spiegel oder so etwas den Finger abnehmen. Dann gibt es kleine Kondensatorplatten, wo also unzählige kleine Kondensatoren drauf sind. Und wenn ich den Finger darauf lege, dann ist die Kapazität je nachdem anders, ob da eine Rille ist oder ein Hügel von dem Fingerabdruck. Dann gibt es, kommen wir vielleicht nachher nochmal im Detail drauf, andere Systeme. Manche sind thermisch, also mit ganz vielen Thermofühlern. Und da, wo eine Rille vom Finger ist, dann ist es etwas kälter als woanders. Dann gibt es Systeme, wo man den Finger drüber ziehen muss, wo dann über ein Verfahren die Tiefe der Rille noch gemessen wird. Wichtig dabei ist, es gibt eine ganze Menge Versuche, jetzt rauszufinden, ist denn dieser Finger echt, sprich ist er lebendig. Weil man könnte ja sonst auch jemandem einfach den Finger abhacken und zack, hat man da auch Zugang. Das will man natürlich vermeiden durch diese sogenannte Lebenderkennung. Die war da bei diesem Gerät ganz clever gelöst. Da musste man den Finger also reinstecken und auf so eine Scheibe legen. Und da wurde dann gleichzeitig von oben mit einer roten Leuchtdiode durchgeleuchtet. Und dadurch, dass das Blut durch den Finger pulst, wird das ständig mal ein klein bisschen dunkler. Man sah das auch auf dem Bild, auf dem Monitor, auf dem Vergleichsbild. Das pulste so im Sekundentakt. Das konnte ja wohl nur die Herzfrequenz sein. Was haben wir also getan? Haben das Zigarettenpapierchen da rauf gelegt, haben mit einem zweiten, auch transparenten Zigarettenpapierchen im Sekundentakt zwischen die Leuchtdiode und den Sensor gehalten und Katschungen waren wir wieder drin. Der Finger war lebendig. Und so zog sich das eigentlich durch diese ganzen Experimente durch. Am Ende, wir waren dann sehr advanced am Schluss, haben wir den Finger auf einen Scanner gelegt, was ja nichts anderes ist als einen Fingerprint-Scanner letzten Endes. Haben den Finger also mit einem 1200 DPI-Scanner, die heute auch nur noch 100 Mark kosten, abgescannt, haben das ausgedruckt, daraus einen Stempel hergestellt. Mit diesem Stempel kann man dann, wenn man den auch in die richtige Temperatur bringt und wenn der dann ein transparentes Material ist, eigentlich einen Finger perfekt simulieren. Und das ist auch die große Schwäche von diesen biometrischen Systemen. Sie basieren immer ausnahmslos auf physikalischen Eigenschaften. Gleich welche das sind, ob das jetzt Optik ist, ob das Lichtstrahlen sind und so weiter, physikalische Eigenschaften, die man messen kann, kann man mit Sicherheit immer auch herstellen.
Also darf ich kurz für den Businessman oder für die drei von den 100.000, die wir um heute Abend zuhören kurz dazwischenfragen, diese ganzen komischen Laptops, die es momentan gibt, für 12.000 Mark und mehr, wo dann irgendwie schon das System mit ist, mit Fingerprint und so, das ist Bullshit, oder?
Ja, das ist nicht unsicherer als ein Windows Passwort.
Also es bringt sicherlich, also sagen wir so, es ist nicht unsicherer, so etwas zu haben, aber es ist jetzt nicht so unüberwindlich, wie man glaubt und im einfachsten Fall klemmt man es halt einfach ab oder bootet halt das System.
Oder baut die Platte aus.
Oder baut die Platte aus oder andere Dinge. Also insofern, es ist ein ganz nettes Gimmick und spart einem vielleicht das Passwort einzugeben.
Gerade für Business-Leute ist es wesentlich wichtiger, dass sie ihre relevanten Daten einfach verschlüsselt auf dem Laptop speichern, dass wenn der abhanden kommt, nicht auch gleich die ganzen Firmengeheimnisse mit abhanden kommen. Das ist ja immer unangenehm. Aber um zum Fingerabdrück zurückzukommen, das steht völlig recht, dass jedes beliebige physikalische Merkmal des Körpers kopierbar ist. Aber Fingerabdrücke sind trotzdem eine besondere Qualität, weil man sie einfach überall hinterlässt, wo man geht und steht. Also Experimente, wo man seinen Finger in Wachs taucht, gut und schön, aber wenn man sich mal einen reellen Angriff durchdenkt, dann wird man schlecht die Zielperson dazu kriegen, dass sie ihren Finger in Wachs steckt. Logisch. Das macht es nicht komplizierter. Bei Fingerabdrücken ist es immer noch möglich. Bei anderen Sachen ist es nicht möglich. Einen Irisabdruck hinterlässt man einfach nicht. An jedem Bierglas, das man erfasst.
Da kann man definitiv sagen, Irisabdruck ist aber auch etwas, was von außen immerhin noch einem abgenommen werden kann. Im Gegensatz zu einem Retina-Scan, der wird deswegen gerne in wirklichen Hochsicherheitsbereichen eingesetzt. Also, was weiß ich, Silos, um Atomraketen abzuschießen, ist so ein typischer Anwendungsfall für einen Retina-Scanner. Aber normalen Menschen wird man das nicht zumuten wollen.
Und selbst beim Retina-Scan würde ich jetzt noch einwenden. Ja, aber, genau ob Fingerprint oder Handgeometrie oder Unterschrift, es gibt die Geräte, die das abnehmen. Und die hat nicht nur einer, die haben viele Leute. Beim Fingerprint ist es ein halben. Spätestens und zuletzt kriege ich deinen Fingerabdruck, weil ich selbst einen Fingerprint-Scanner anbiete und sage, du kommst hier nur rein, wenn du deinen Finger darauf liest und dich authentifizierst oder identifizierst. Genauso ist es beim Retina-Scan. Sobald noch jemand anderes, außer das Raketenabschuss-Silo, auch Retina-Scan einsetzt, ist der auch im Besitz deiner Retina. So ist das halt. Und die lässt sich auch simulieren. Das ist schwierig, aber immer sicher. Noch mal rufen wir uns ins Gedächtnis, Sicherheit ist nur insoweit... Also es gibt nicht sicher, es gibt nur sicher genug. Das heißt, die Sicherheit ist dann gewährleistet, wenn der zu erwartende Nutzen geringer ist, weil es der Aufwand, den ich treiben muss, um sie zu durchbrechen. Aber um so eine Atomrakete zu kriegen, da kann man schon mal auf Land treiben.
Ich denke ja immer nur in Filmen, das ist mir aufgefallen, jetzt am Anfang des heutigen Abends. Zwei Filme, die ich anbringen möchte, der eine ist Getter Car, wo es um Genetische, also geht es über Blut, glaube ich, und über Haare und halt die genetische, also die Genomidentifizierung im Grunde und daran erkennen oder, was gab es noch, Alien 4, wo man irgendwo rein atmet und an Pheromonen oder irgendwie sowas wahrscheinlich erkannt wird.
Also der Körpergeruch ist tatsächlich auch ein biometrisches Merkmal, was ja zum Beispiel die Stasi auch genutzt hat. Die haben im großen Umfang Geruchsproben der Dissidenten hauptsächlich angefertigt und dann allerdings nicht mit Computern, sondern mit runden Nasen das Ganze verglichen. Und das funktionierte wohl auch durchaus gut. Ja, aber wo wir gerade noch vielleicht der Vollständigkeit halber, wo wir beim Finger waren, beim Fingerabdruckerkennungssystem, ein großes Problem bei allen biometrischen Verfahren ist, wo lege ich die Schwellwerte? Also wann, weil ich bekomme ja einen Grad der Übereinstimmung und muss jetzt sagen, okay, bei 93, 95 oder 99 Prozent Übereinstimmung sage ich jetzt ist okay oder weise ab. Und einerseits will ich natürlich, verlange ich nun möglichst, je höher ich den Grad der Übereinstimmung verlange, umso sicherer wird das System. Aber gleichzeitig steigt auch die Zahl der falschen Abweisungen. Und falsche Abweisungen, zum Beispiel beim Fingerabdruckscanner, können durch eine ganze Reihe von Faktoren erzeugt werden. Und jedes System hat seine Faktoren, mit denen man das beeinträchtigen kann. Und beim Fingerabdruck fängt es schon mal an mit kalten Fingern. Das ist ein Riesenproblem. Also wenn die Finger kalt sind, damit haben die meisten Fingerabdruckscanner riesige Probleme. Dann, wenn die Finger zu trocken sind, wird es schwierig. Oder wenn die Finger ölig sind, hat man ein Problem. Wenn die Luftfeuchtigkeit besonders hoch ist, oder wenn die Luftfeuchtigkeit besonders niedrig ist, wenn ich meinen Finger ein bisschen schräg draufsetze, oder wenn ich zu fest oder zu wenig fest drücke, wenn ich den Finger nicht genau in die Mitte setze, oder wenn ich Kratzer auf meiner Fingeroberfläche habe, oder wenn ich irgendwie jetzt gemauert habe oder vorher in meinem Garten gegraben habe, dann hat das System eben auch seine Schwierigkeiten und weist mich ab, obwohl ich eigentlich berechtigt wäre. Naja, ich komm halt nicht rein. Ich kann dann mein Laptop nicht benutzen, beispielsweise. Oder darf das Flugzeug nicht besteigen, weil ich nicht der bin, der Computer.
Ich würde das am liebsten mal vergleichen, dieser Schwellwert oder diese Schwelle, die man da annehmen muss. Das ist genau tatsächlich der Knackpunkt an der Geschichte. Ich muss hergehen und sagen, ich toleriere bestimmte Ungenauigkeiten, weil der Mensch ist nun mal kein präzises Instrument, das immer gleich aussieht, immer gleich riecht. Hast du eine Infektion, riechst du ganz anders, bist du verliebt, riechst du ganz anders. Und so weiter und so weiter. Dieser Schwellwert, der ist sehr, sehr schwierig zu bestimmen und der ist dann auch mit Untermal, unterhalb dieser Schwelle hast du dann schon doppelte. Das heißt, wenn die Schwelle zu niedrig ist, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit auch viel höher, dass zwei verschiedene Personen auf dieselben Merkmale noch treffen.
Wir haben ein lustiges Experiment gemacht mit einem Gesichtserkennungssystem, wo man fünf Fotos einreichen musste, als Muster gegen das überprüft wurde. Da haben wir zwei Fotos von der einen Person genommen, drei Fotos der anderen Person, siehe da plötzlich gegen beide Personen als dieselbe Person durch.
So was zum Beispiel. Wir haben auch mal getestet, einen Gesichtsscanner, der eine ganz pfiffige Kombination macht, das muss man ja schon wirklich als innovativ bezeichnen. Da wurde das Gesicht aufgenommen mit einer Kamera und gleichzeitig musste man einen vorher nicht bekannten Satz, der stand auf dem Display, den musste man sagen. Dabei hat er die Bewegung des Mundes abgenommen und das musste einer bestimmten Charakteristik entsprechen. Gleichzeitig wurde die Mikrobewegung des Auges mitgemessen. Das heißt, das Auge steht ja, auch wenn man gerade ausguckt, nicht die ganze Zeit still, sondern es bewegt sich. Vor allem bewegt es sich einmal in der Minimalbewegung, so ein leichtes Zittern, und zum zweiten bewegt es sich, wenn man diese Schrift abliest vom Display, um dann vorzulesen, was da steht. Das klingt jetzt echt innovativ, es war relativ leicht zu durchbrechen. Man nimmt ein Foto von der Person, um die es geht, macht da, wo die Augen sind, zwei Löcher rein, und liest nicht etwa diesen Satz ab, sondern spricht ihn, der hat dann, okay, der hat dann auch noch eine Geräuschaufnahme, aber das haben sie schon gar nicht wirklich ausreichend identifiziert. Und gleichzeitig knautscht man im Mundbereich dieses Foto ein bisschen. Das hat gereicht, das ist völlig ausreichend, weil die Merkmal, die Schwelle muss groß sein, weil wenn ich nach einer Party vor dem Ding stehe, hab eine total rauchige Stimme und bin sowieso... Ja, morgens früh, voll scheiße vor dem Ding und das lässt mich nicht rein und ich werde jedes Mal wütender. So, dann ist natürlich die Toleranz irgendwann gleich Null.
Wobei man auch sagen muss, da liegen ja genau die Unterschiede zwischen Authentifikation und Identifikation. Bei einer Authentifikation reicht mir möglicherweise 80 oder 90 Prozent aus, dann dreh ich halt an der Grenze die Erkennungsverschwendigkeit runter. Wenn ich jedes Mal eine 1 aus 10 Chance habe, dass ich über die Grenze komme, dann spätestens bei der dritten haben sie mich mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von 1 zu 1000. Und dann ist das nicht so ein Problem. Wie viel größeres Problem ist, wenn man sich einbildet, man könnte da eine Kamera hinhängen und die schlägt dann Alarm, wenn ein Terrorist vorbeikommt. Das wird schiefgehen.
Zumal vielleicht, wo wir gerade auch noch bei der Gesichtserkennung schon mal gelandet sind, auch da gibt es natürlich eine ganze Reihe von Faktoren, die die Erkennung beeinträchtigen jetzt wiederum, die einen dazu zwingen, diese diese Schwelle runterzusetzen. Und bei der Gesichtserkennung fängt es halt schon mal an mit dem Bart. Also Bart mögen die meisten Gesichtserkennungssysteme nicht wirklich.
Der Taliban.
Wenn man den ändert, dann einfach den Haarschnitt. Also Haarschnittänderung, also wenn ich meinen Haar in die Stirn habe oder eine Glatze, ist das auch schon ein Riesenproblem für viele Systeme.
Also nicht mehr zum Friseur.
Dann das Lichtverhältnis macht, den meisten zu schaffen. Also je nachdem von wo das Licht gerade an einfällt. Das heißt, in Bereichen, wo Tageslicht herrscht, haben solche Erkennungssysteme einen fast unmöglichen Job zu leisten. Dann hat man Probleme mit Leuchtstoffröhren, weil die wiederum riesige Störungen in den Kameras verursachen. Hüte machen auch ein Riesenproblem oder Schirmmützen, weil die auch die Leuchtungssituation verändern und die Kopfform variieren.
Ich müsste da einfach mal auf den Fernseher zeigen. Da war nämlich erst eine BKA-Webseite zu sehen mit einem Täterregister und jetzt ein Mensch, der an einem Flugzeugsimulator auf Türme zusteuert und dabei einen Joint raucht.
Wir schauen RTL, das muss man dazu sagen. Und der Joint ist unglaublich schlecht gebaut. Zumindest sieht aus wie so ein Frauen-Joint, etwas lang.
Der trifft sich ein bisschen aus wie Kimbell, aber...
Kommt auch, ja. Vielleicht kann ich noch kurz die Liste vollenden. Wann, womit halt so Gesichtserkennungssysteme Probleme haben. Gewichtsabnahme oder Zunahme mögen die Systeme auch nicht. Also so ein Monat, zwei Fastenkur oder so. Und es ist auch nicht... Dann so Kopf auf die Seite legen, macht es auch schwieriger, dass die Verfahren können. Es ist zwar korrigieren, aber es wird dann trotzdem schwieriger. Wenn man sich zu viel oder zu wenig bewegt, dann ist die Qualität der jeweiligen Kamera macht auch noch einen Unterschied. Und dann die Umgebung. Wenn also die Umgebung auch zu unruhig ist, der Hintergrund, dann versagen viele Gesichtserkennungssysteme.
Also wir haben gelernt, auch hier alles ganz einfach. Gar kein Problem eigentlich, völlig zuverlässig. Wollen wir vielleicht nochmal beleuchten, was eigentlich, weil wir da vorhin schon mal waren, haben wir schon mal versucht, darauf hinzusteuern, sind wir ein bisschen abgeglitten, was denn eigentlich das Wünschenswerte wäre für eine Zugangsbeschränkung, Authentifizierung, Identifizierung. Und da fällt mir eigentlich nur das Beispiel ein, der perfekte Passwortschutz ist eigentlich der, wo nur das System und ich ein jeweils jedesmal änderndes und völlig zufälliges Passwort kennen.
Und wir müssen beide drauf kommen, oder was?
Nein, nein, man muss halt vorher vereinbart haben, wie das sein soll. Das heißt, man tauscht auf einem sicheren Kanal eine mögliche Menge von Passworten aus und gewährleistet das, ohne dass jemand dazwischen stehen kann, ich dem System dieses Passwort auf einem nicht wahrnehmbaren Kanal mitteile. Das ist ein Ideal, ist schon klar. Und das System stellt fest, aha, das ist das richtige Passwort, also stimmt.
So Tannblog-mäßig, oder was?
Ja, nicht Tannblog, da gibt es noch andere Probleme. Da wollen wir heute mal ausnahmsweise nicht drauf eingehen. Das ist auch nicht so richtig sicher, aber im Prinzip schon mit ein paar Feinheiten.
Oh, dann komme ich an der Grenze nicht raus, weil ich meinen Tannblog nicht rechtzeitig erinnere.
Nein, ich wollte nur beschreiben, was eigentlich nötig wäre, um eine vernünftige, zukünftige Zugangsbeschränkung hinzubekommen und dazu im Gegenüber mal zu stellen. Wir haben festgestellt, das Merkmal eines solchen Zugangsschutzes sollte sein, es sollte einmalig sein, es sollte sich also jedes Mal verändern, es sollte niemandem außer mir und dem System bekannt sein. Und es sollte natürlich auch ausreichend komplex sein, um nicht erraten werden zu können. Jetzt gucken wir uns mal so einen Fingerabdruck im Gegenüber an. Ein Fingerabdruck, da habe ich maximal genau 10 Stück von. Das heißt, wenn einer verraucht ist, weil der im Internet gelandet ist, dann habe ich nur noch neun. Irgendwann ist da mal Schluss. Dieses Ding kann man also nicht permanent ändern. Zweites Problem, man hinterlässt es ständig permanent überall. Das gilt für das Gesicht auch. Also Kameras gibt es nun reichhaltig überall. Das sind Sachen, die hinterlassig andauernd. Den Fingerabdruck, der ist auf jedem Glas, auf jedem Papier, auf jedem Plastik, auf jedem Wahlzettel, den ich ausfülle.
Das ist ja auch durch die Presse gegen ganz nett, ob man demnächst dann mit Gummihandschuhen zur Wahl gehen muss.
Nächster Aspekt, er ist leicht zu fälschen. Er ist nicht sehr komplex. Es werden gerade mal 8 Minuten ausgewertet von so einem Fingerabdruck. Minuten sind die besonderen Merkmale dieser Rillen im Finger. Gabelungen, besonders schiefe Krumme oder eckige Teile usw. Enge Kurven, weite Kurven usw. Da werden einfach 8 Merkmale rausgesucht. Die müssen dann identisch sein. Es ist nicht sehr komplex. Es ist überhaupt nicht leicht änderbar. Es ist für jeden sichtbar. Es ist also das absolute Gegenteil von dem, was man sich wünschen würde, um eine sichere Zugangsbeschränkung oder Zugangsgestattung einzustellen.
Wir hatten ja vorhin schon mal kurz, da wollte ich noch mal was nachfragen, diesen Fall, dass wenn man sowas einführen würde im ganz großen Stil, tatsächlich alle, die mit Authentifizierung oder Identifizierung zu tun haben, so ein System am Start haben. Das heißt, spätestens dann, wenn ich irgendwo hingehe, wo nicht der Start am Start ist, sozusagen, sondern irgendeine andere Institution, die nimmt mir meinen Iris oder meinen Fingerdruck, dann haben die den. Das heißt, eigentlich könnte man so ein großes System gar nicht machen, weil ich möchte dann in meinem, sozusagen in meinem Unternehmen mein System haben, die anderen wissen gar nicht, welches System das ist und so. Das heißt, es ist von vornherein zum Scheitern verurteilt.
Eigentlich schon. Also man muss auch bedenken, genauso wie es heute immer wieder passiert, dass meine Kreditkartendaten, die ich leichtfertig im Internet irgendwo eingetippt habe, plötzlich zu Hunderttausenden da in Dateien im Internet auftauchen. So wird es auch sein, dass da ein Fingerabdruck da auftaucht von Hunderttausend Leuten. Der Unterschied bei der Kreditkarte ist, die kann ich sperren lassen. Das ist ganz einfach.
Aber du kannst auch den Finger abpacken.
So ist es nicht. Ja, aber den kann ich halt nicht ändern. Und dann ist der da und meine Nase auch, mein Gesicht auch. Hey, wow.
Also ein riesiges Problem in den USA hauptsächlich, aber ist der sogenannte Identitätsdiebstahl, der den Leuten wirklich riesig zu schaffen macht. Jetzt kann man natürlich darüber diskutieren, ob mit zusätzlicher, mit Biometrie der Identitätsdiebstahl schwieriger wird oder leichter. Aber auf jeden Fall werden die Auswirkungen natürlich schwieriger, wenn so ein Identitätsdiebstahl erfolgt. Das heißt, im einfachsten Fall in den USA bestellen sich dann Leute auf fremde Kreditkarte mit fremder Sozialversicherungsnummer oder anderen fremden Dokumenten Waren oder tun irgendwelche illegalen Dinge. Und es fällt dann auf denjenigen zurück, von dem die Identität gestohlen wurde. Und der hat dann teilweise jahrelang damit zu kämpfen, dass er keinen Kredit mehr bekommt und nicht weiß, warum, dass er kein Auto mehr zulassen kann, dass er keine Wohnung mehr bekommen kann. Gut, das sind alles Dinge, die bei uns versucht, das Datenschutzgesetz zu etwas zu vermeiden. Aber das ist durchaus mit das größte Gefahrenpotential, wenn meine Identität dann mal in falsche Hände gerät und wenn der Fingerabdruck allgemein zur Identifikation herangezogen wird, dann ist das natürlich sehr, sehr schwerwiegend. Und ich hab dann meine große Not zu beweisen, dass ich unschuldig bin, wenn mein Fingerabdruck aber am Ort hinterlassen wurde. Man sieht die ganze Diskussion um EC-Karten und Pins, welches Problem ich immer noch habe, wenn jemand meine EC-Karte stielt, Geld damit abhebt, dass dann nach wie vor meist davon ausgegangen wird, ich hätte irgendwie fahrlässig gehandelt. Und wie lange man prozessieren muss und mit ungewissem Ausgang, um da eben seine Unschuld eigentlich zu beweisen, was ja eher umgekehrt sein sollte.
Ja, wollen wir ein bisschen Musik machen?
Würde ich sogar vorschlagen.
Wir machen erst mal eine Musik. Ich ergänze noch mal, dass wenn so ein Fingerabdruck dann mit der Pin abgefragt wird beim Geldautomaten und dann tatsächlich jemand Geld abgehoben hat mit meiner Pin und meinem Fingerabdruck und ich war es nicht, habe ich es um Größenordnung schwerer zu beweisen, dass ich es nicht gewesen bin und dass ich hier nicht Betrug versuche, sondern dann ist die Schwelle, dass die glauben, dass das ein Irrtum ist, wesentlich geringer. Und dabei ist es genauso leicht wie nur mit Pin. Also Pin und Fingerabdruck zusammen ist nicht besonders viel schwerer.
Jedenfalls nicht für die entsprechenden Kriminellen, die sehr kreativ agieren.
Und Not macht erfinderisch und wenn der Kriminelle nicht mehr nur mit der Pin da rankommt, dann wird er sich was überlegen.
Wobei der kreative Kriminelle ist ein Bild, das ich sehr schätze. Das muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, das gefällt mir. Es geht um Biometrie beim heutigen Chaosradio Blue Moon. Wir hören jetzt ein bisschen Musik und gleich machen wir die Telefone auf. Genau. Musikalische Untermalung für das Chaosradio am heutigen Abend. 23.05 Uhr haben wir es. Es geht um das Thema Biometrie und am Start heute der Steini, der Andreas und der Pavel. Wunderschönen guten Abend. Und ihr könnt jetzt auch anrufen. Wir haben ja schon mal im großen Stil geklärt, worum es sich bei Biometrie handelt, was so die schönen Sachen an der Sache sind, dass man zum Beispiel andere Leute Fingerabdrücke fälschen kann, wenn man möchte und wenn man ein kreativer Krimineller ist. Ich betone das nochmal. Ihr könnt anrufen unter 0331 70 97 1 1 0, wenn ihr kreative Kriminelle seid, aber auch wenn ihr euch einfach für das Thema interessiert. 0331 77 97 1 0.
Und was wir von euch wissen wollen, ist, was haltet ihr denn von diesen Schily-Paketen, diesen Otto-Versand-Katalog? Was haltet ihr eigentlich von dieser neuen Methodik, euch zu erkennen, ob jetzt zum Zugang oder einfach so auf der Straße? Wir haben ja gehört, in Großbritannien gibt es 30.000 Kameras, die da in London in der Innenstadt stehen und so weiter. Was haltet ihr davon? Wie geht ihr damit um? Was werdet ihr tun? Werdet ihr in Zukunft zu Wahlen mit Handschuhen gehen? Werdet ihr immer mit einer Schirm-Mütze rumlaufen? Oder wie in Afghanistan mit einem Schleier, jetzt auch die Männer? Wie werdet ihr damit umgehen, dass ihr, wenn das alles durchgeht in Zukunft, ihr überall immer von allem erkannt werdet, mehr oder weniger zuverlässig und dabei auch mehr oder weniger sicher mehrfach in Probleme kommt, weil man euch für jemanden hält, den ihr gar nicht seid oder weil man euch nicht für den hält, den ihr tatsächlich seid.
Am Telefon ist erstmal der Tristan aus Schöneberg. Tristan.
Hallo.
Der was zum, naja, zu einem Verfahren im Grunde zu sagen hat.
Genau, also ich meine, die größte Frage ist natürlich im Prinzip, wie kann man das fälschen erstmal und wie kann man das möglichst sicher machen? Und ich dachte mir eigentlich, was ihr die ganze Zeit angesprochen hat, so mit Iris und Gesichtserkennung und Fingerabdruck und Handgeometrie und so, das sind alles so Fragmente eines Menschen, die man irgendwie doch so aller Gipsguss und aller Silikonabdruck irgendwie abnehmen kann. Aber wie ist es mit dem ganzen Körper, wenn man den ganzen Körper sozusagen meines Wegen röntgt oder sonst was?
Wow, ein Röntchen ist ein gutes Beispiel.
Ich lass mich bestimmt 40 mal am Tag röntchen.
Hab ich voll Bock drauf.
Es hängt von der Dosis ab. Man kann ja auch ganz schwache Strahle oder meines Wegen Kernspindfotografen. Das ist ein teueres Ding, aber es geht ja auch nicht.
Ja, dann so, was kostet so 4 bis 500 Mark pro Identifizierung ist natürlich echt günstig.
Ich meine, es muss ja nicht unbedingt in medizinisch guter, perfekter Qualität sein, sondern es gibt ja bestimmt auch Methoden, mein Wegen mit Ultraschall einen Körper zu durchleuchten, wie man es bei schwangeren Frauen kennt oder sonst was. Ich kann mir vorstellen, zum Beispiel, man kann ziemlich schlecht eine dreidimensionale Puppe bauen als Dummy dafür, um das zu cracken. Das System, wo mein Wegen Leberherzen und Niere und alles und so weiter an der Position sind, wie es bei mir, meinem Namen, meinem Körper genau ist.
Nur, es geht ja nicht um Sicherheit bei der ganzen Sache, sondern es geht um Ökonomie letztendlich.
Ja gut, natürlich. Dafür ist meine Idee natürlich nicht so besonders, weil man es nicht so leicht machen kann.
Für Ultraschall komplett den Körper eingehlen, bevor man überhaupt rein darf. Das ist sexy, aber es ist nicht jedermanns Sache, nicht?
Ey, ich weiß nicht, es kommt drauf an.
Hast du irgendwann mal irgendwelche Erfahrungen gemacht, bzw. was wirst du tun, wenn du gezwungen wirst, deinen Fingerabdruck abzugeben oder wenn überall Kameras hängen wirst du sagen, ja ist okay, wunderbar, dann bin ich endlich sicher oder wie wirst du damit umgehen?
Also ich zähle mich sozusagen zu den harmlosen Kreativen kriminell weniger. Also ich würde schon sagen, dass ich probieren würde nach dem Motto, dann und da musst du deinen Fingerabdruck abgeben, würde ich wahrscheinlich vorher irgendwie mal eine heiße Herzplatte kurz untouchen. Nach dem Motto, der Fingerabdruck ist irgendwie nur noch zu 10% von seiner Tiefe da oder irgendwie würde ich probieren, glaube ich, immer so Systeme zu verarschen. Ich meine, was für mich dann wahrscheinlich im Einzelfall dann doch eher die döberen Folgen hätte, aber trotzdem. Ne, was ich auch witzig finde, ist zum Beispiel, habe ich mir ein Radio gebastelt, was nun wirklich kein Problem ist. Ich bastel ziemlich viel mit Elektronik rum, habe gerade einen Freund neue Handybeleuchtung eingebaut etc. Wo ich morgens so als Stadtradio oder zum Radio oder wie auch immer mal einen Polizeifunk abhöre und mal höre, was für ganze Autos mit Nummernschild, Identifikation und so weiter und Strafregister, was teilweise auch dann durchgefaxed wird.
Also es ist in Deutschland zwar legal, den Polizeifunk zu hören, es ist aber nicht legal darüber zu reden, dass man ihn gehört hat, nur so als Sicherheitshinweis.
Ne, man darf den Inhalt nicht weitergeben. Man darf darüber reden, dass jemand so, ey ich hab Polizeifunk gehört, glaube ich schon. Man darf nur die Info, die Daten an sich nicht andere so weitergeben.
Du darfst es nur, wenn du eine Funklizenz besitzt, also Inhaber einer Funklizenz bist. Dann darf es dir passieren, dass du aus Versehen den...
Ich finde es so amüsant, weil es ist pipi einfach und man kann wirklich, also ich habe schon die spektakulärsten Verfolgungsjagden direkt von meiner Ausstür mitgekriegt und ich finde es einfach interessant, dass man sowas zum Beispiel nicht schützt. Also ich weiß, dass es ziemlich einfach ist, verbale Kommunikation zu verschlüsseln und das ist echt kein Ding und da würde ich zum Beispiel nicht so schnell abhören können.
Aber das wird ja erst seit fünf bis zehn Jahren dran gearbeitet und in weiteren fünf bis zehn Jahren, denke ich, ist das dann auch besser.
Tetrapol heißt das System, sollte eigentlich schon zum Regierungsumzug in Betrieb gehen. Da ist doch wieder Verzögerung gegeben, ist eine ähnliche Geschichte wie bei dem Inpolneu auch, wo unglückliche Mengen Geld draufgeworfen werden, Probleme zu lösen, wo man sich fragt, wie die auch kommen.
Das ist genau der Punkt. Wenn wir mal sehen, dass sowas wirklich einfach ist, schon nicht einführbar und funktional zu bauen, sodass es dann auch für den einfachen Polizisten da draußen zu bedienen ist und funktioniert, ohne dass der damit Probleme kriegt und dann zwei Jahre geschubbelt werden muss, dann kannst du dir mal vorstellen, wie knifflig das wird, wenn der andere Geräte bedienen muss, oder wenn da bestimmte neue Technologien eingeführt werden, die einfach um Größenordnung komplexer sind als Sprachverschlüsselung.
Immerhin kriegen wir aber jetzt demnächst schon mal den neuen Personalausweis. Habt ihr den eigentlich mal gesehen, habt ihr euch den mal angeschaut?
Ich auch nicht.
Also es gibt, also ich hab mir mal, also bei der Bundesdruckerei, die hat im Web das Ganze... Die Vorlagen. Ja, die Vorlagen sind auch für die wichtigsten Sicherheitsnachmale. Und ich mein, der ist eigentlich nicht zu beanstanden. Also da sind halt hauptsächlich lauter Hologramme mit eingearbeitet. Ich mein, es ist Schnickschnack. Er ist sicherlich ein gutes Stück schwieriger zu fälschen als der jetzige Personalausweis.
Und auch in China wurden auch Hologramme von Microsoft-Produkten gefälscht. Also ganz unmöglich ist das nicht.
Ja, unmöglich nicht, aber er steigert deutlich nochmal die Schwellen und er glitzert schön und bunt und sieht halt jetzt mit einem 100 Mark Schein ein bisschen ähnlicher. Aber das ist jedenfalls, ich meine, das ist nur ein bisschen teurer. Ich sag mal, da hab ich nicht so das Problem mit.
Ich glaube, das Problem hier ist, dass die Technologie, die man aufwendet, um neue solche Elemente auf so was raufzubringen, ist immer im gleichen Rhythmus besser geworden, wie die Technologie das dann zu fälschen. Also wenn Microsoft Hologramme draufmacht oder auf Personalausweisen und Geldscheinen Hologramme drauf sind, ja nun, dann wird's halt Technologie geben, um solche Hologramme auch zu machen. Es ist ja offenbar möglich, weil die Bundesdruckerei schafft das ja auch.
Ich bin mir auch sicher, dass sich irgendjemand an eine Technologie ausdenken wird, wenn der Bedarf besteht, um dreidimensionale Artbilder deiner inneren Organe zu erzeugen. Oder zumindest etwas, was in der Lage ist, denselben Input an den Scanner zu liefern.
Aber, Jungs, also was mir jetzt irgendwie nach einer Stunde und 20 Minuten wieder bewusst wird, ist eine Frage, warum zum Teufel wollen wir das überhaupt? Weil die Systeme sind viel, viel teurer als alles andere, was man sich vorstellen kann. Sie sind scheiße und der Blick eines Menschen, den man mit einem 630 Mark-Job beschäftigt, sind immer besser als alles andere.
Ja, also das hat natürlich auch was, speziell wenn wir da kurz noch mal auf Schily zurückkommen wollen. Das hatte Andy neulich auch so schön erzählt auf dem Vortrag, der arme Mann hat es ja nicht leicht. Zu seiner Aufgabe gehört es ja irgendwie, das Sicherheitsgefühl der Bürger irgendwo zu verbessern. Weil an der Sicherheit kann er nur leider nicht wirklich so viel tun. Aber die ist auch überhaupt nicht relevant. Wichtig ist halt das Sicherheitsgefühl. Zur Steigerung des Sicherheitsgefühls schickt man Polizisten auf die Straße und macht Hologramme rein und redet über Fingerabdrücke im Personalausweis. Und schon fühlen sich alle irgendwie sicherer.
Das heißt, wir haben hier einen Blender.
Darf ich mal ganz kurz unseren Anrufer fragen, ob er sich jetzt sicherer fühlt?
Einerseits fühle ich mich, weiß ich nicht, also für mich ist Sicherheit für mich eigentlich nicht so ein großes Problem, weil ich mich sowieso ziemlich unerkannt fühle. Also ich weiß nicht warum, aber ich denke immer so, wenn mich jemand suchen würde und ich das Spitz kriege, rechtzeitig durch Polizeifunkte oder was auch immer, könnte ich glaube ich schnell genug irgendwo hin abhauen, wo man mich erstmal in ziemlich langer Zeit nicht finden würde.
Hast du eine Bahncard? Nein.
Ich habe auch kein Computer und trotzdem kriege ich erstaunlicherweise... SMS auf mein Handy.
Du hast eine Telefonzelle in der Hosentasche. Also da wissen sie ja auch immer genau, wo du bist.
Das Wichtigste ist nur, dass ich immer so SMS kommen, nach dem Motto, ich habe zwei runde Äpfel und ein süßes Laume, willst du nicht deine Banane bei mir versenken? Das sind 090er-Nummern, die man nicht zurückschreiben kann, nach dem Motto, wer bist du dumme Kuh?
Wo hast du denn dann deine geheime Telefonnummer hinterlassen?
Ich verdammt würde es auch gerne mal wissen. Das ist aber verdächtig irgendwie.
Du hast die vielleicht ins Web eingetippt, bei diesen tollen, kostenlosen Services. Das sollte man auf keinen Fall tun. Irgendwo ins Web seine Telefonnummer eintippen.
Das ist einmal gemacht, stimmt. Wahrscheinlich war es das mal. Ganz kurz zum Thema, noch ein bisschen anderes Thema, ganz kurz wollte ich immer noch erzählen, das fand ich super amüsant, ist auch schon mindestens anderthalb oder zwei Jahre her, da haben zwei Jungs sich mal einen Streich gemacht und haben einen 30-Mark-Schein zusammengebastelt. Ich weiß nicht, wo es war irgendwo in Deutschland, und die Gassiererinnen haben beschrieben, hatten wir ziemlich blöd geguckt, hatten nicht gewusst, wo wir den einsortieren sollten, die Schublade von der Kasse, hat es aber durchgehen lassen.
Die Bundesbank hat Berge von solchen nachgemachten Spaßgeldscheinen, die finden das nicht so lustig. Das ist bestimmt ganz schön verboten. Die finden diese Art von Geschenken nicht so lustig.
Bei der Gelegenheit fällt mir ein, dass es momentan natürlich eine echte Schwemme geben wird von Falschgeld, weil der Euro kommt und die alten Lappen müssen weg.
Im Moment merkst du ja auch, wenn du irgendwo bezahlst, die haben die Kontrollen deutlich erhöht. Sie kontrollieren jetzt überall mit UV und gucken sich die Geldscheine.
Tristan, danke dir erst mal bis zu dem Punkt. Wir arbeiten weiter am 35 Mark Schein, nicht?
Moment, noch ganz kurz eine Sache. Und zwar meine ich, dass man doch vielleicht das Geld stimmt, was man in die 3D Körper Röntgenscanner oder sonst was einbringt, dass man vielleicht doch irgendwie daran hindern sollte, die Quellen der Kriminalität irgendwie doch ein bisschen zu reduzieren. Also Schule, sonst was.
Ja, ich bin der Erste, der dich für den Ultraschall eingehlt. Verspreche ich dir jetzt schon. Tschüss, Tristan.
Zum Thema Schily fällt mir noch ein schöner Spruch. Ein früher hat Schily die Terroristen gegen den Staat verteidigt, heute verteidigt er den Staat gegen die Terroristen.
Ja, man muss beide Seiten kennen, nicht? Er wird wahrscheinlich der perfekte Mann dafür sein.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich. Außerdem bin ich ja der Meinung, dass es wahrscheinlich immer noch mehr hilft, die Sicherheit des Staates tatsächlich zu steigern, wenn man mal dafür sorgt, dass die Polizisten besser bezahlt werden, besser ausgerüstet sind, besser motiviert werden. Dann sind die auch irgendwie immer so schlecht gelaunt, wenn man da hinkommt, sondern sind vielleicht besser gelaunt.
Ja, und nicht so lange arbeiten müssen, das finde ich auch.
Darf ich kurz noch eine kleine Anekdote aus dem Leben meines Vaters erzählen?
Der ist Polizist oder was?
Nein, aber es geht auch um Identifikationsmethoden. Mein Vater war, das war zu Raftzeiten, er ist ungefähr 1, 95 Meter groß, dicht, ein Bad und sieht halt auch gefährlich aus. Wenn er möchte, sieht es so ein bisschen türkisch aus, nicht wahr? Also wenn der Teppich hinten drin hätte, wär es halt wirklich vorbei gewesen zu der Zeit. Und er stand in Düsseldorf in einer Passage und guckte sich Bücher an und es fuhr eine Wanne vorbei, so in 20 Metern Entfernung, da saß eine junge Frau drin. Mein Vater ist Lehrer, das muss man dazu sagen. Diese junge Frau winkte ihm aus diesem Wagen zu und er dachte sich, das wird schon eine Schülerin sein. Und winkte zurück und guckte sich wieder die Bücher an und 5 Sekunden später sprinteten 4 Uniformierte um die Ecke, rissen ihn zu Boden, haben ihn für 24 Stunden in U-Haft gesteckt, weil sich dann rausstellte, dass eine Terroristin war, die ihm zugewunken hat und er hat gedacht, was der Teufel, wird schon irgendjemand sein. Und das war sehr, sehr schön. So viel zum Thema Identifikation.
Ja, da kann ich gleich eine hinterherschicken, warum ich mich auch so aufgeregt habe, als das mit dem Fingerabdruck abnehmen für alle aufkam. Weil also eine Gelegenheit, bei der ich mal in die Fahndung bzw. ein Ermittlungsverfahren gegen mich eröffnet wurde, war, weil jemand ein Plakat auf mein Auto geklebt hatte, was er von der Wand abgezogen hat. Als ich das dann gesehen habe, so vier, fünf Stunden später, habe ich das halt abgezogen. Aber in der Zwischenzeit war irgendein Polizeibeamter vorbeigegangen, hatte dieses Plakat erkannt und wusste, dass gerade gegen die Plakatierer wegen illegalen Plakatierens oder wegen verbotenen Plakatierens ermittelt wurde. Und schon hatte ich ein Ermittlungsverfahren wegen verbotenen Plakatierens am Hals, weil eben dieses Plakat auf meinem Auto geklebt hat. Und ich hatte dann...
Da hättest du halt rechtzeitig Anzeige erstanden müssen.
Ja, und ich hatte dann wirklich doch ein paar Stunden damit zu tun. Und da kam dann ja auch jemand vom politischen Kommissariat, was ein politisches Plakat gab, der nun jetzt mich halt danach fragte, wie ich denn halt zu diesen Extremisten stiel, die da irgendwie auf dem Plakat erwähnt waren. Und ja, also das fand ich damals überhaupt nicht lustig.
Aber tun wir mal ganz im Ernst, oder? Uns kannst du es doch sagen. Ja, ja, da hat jemand ein Plakat von der Wand abgenommen und ausgerechnet unserem Babel aufs Auto geklebt.
Ja, es war so, sonst hätte ich mich ja nicht aufgeregt.
Nein, natürlich nicht. Du bist natürlich so, hättest du das selbst drauf geklebt, hättest du bei den Bullen gesessen und sagst, selbstverständlich, klar, logisch.
Nein, dann würde ich mich jetzt nicht darüber aufregen.
Okay, ihr könnt weiter anrufen, 03317 77 9110. Es geht in aller Gröbe und Feinheit eben um Biometrie am heutigen Abend beim Chaosradio. Und am Telefon ist der Holm aus Erlangen.
Hallo.
Bei den lustigen Geschichten, die wir jetzt erzählt haben, wo es um den direkten menschlichen Kontakt ging, bist du trotzdem der Meinung, dass der Techniker wichtiger ist als der Wachmann in Zukunft?
Nein, die Frage war eine andere. Die Frage ist, was ist das Entscheidende, um in verboten Systeme zu kommen. Da ist es nicht die Frage, die Technik auszutricksen, sondern jemanden zu kennen, wo man durchkommt. Das heißt, in dem Falle wird in Zukunft nur noch der Techniker bestochen werden, die diese... und nicht mehr der Wachmann für 630 Mark. Sprich, das Bestechen wird auf alle Fälle teurer.
Jetzt richtet sich der Nenig richtig viel teurer. Ich hab mal geguckt, das Bundeskriminalamt schreibt gerade Stellen aus. Da kann man zum Beispiel Systemadministrator für die InPol-Datenbank werden.
640 Mark, damit sich's lohnt.
Nein, BRT5, das ist also kurz über der Putzfrau. Und dafür, dass es eigentlich ein sicherheitsrelevanter Job ist, aber er hat das nette Feature, dass man ab sofort nicht mehr von der Polizei gesucht werden kann, weil man sich einfach aus dem Computer austrägt. Also kann ja mal der eine oder andere drüber nachdenken, den Geld nicht so wichtig ist.
Na wer weiß, in welchem Computer man dann steht, ne?
Bist du vielleicht Techniker, dem man bestechen könnte, oder wie kommst du da drauf?
Naja, so was Ähnliches, ja.
Was heißt so was Ähnliches? Komm jetzt, der Pawel hat auch was verraten über sich und seine Plakate.
Ich bin Elektrotechniker, ja.
Aha, bei einer großen deutschen Firma?
Nein, bei keiner großen deutschen Firma. Bei einem kleinen deutschen Institut.
Und hast du selbst irgendwie mit Biometrie schon mal Kontakt gehabt? Oder eine Meinung dazu?
Na, ich hab mich früher mal ein bisschen mit Bildverarbeitung beschäftigt, aber ich behalte davon relativ wenig, vor allem was so Zugangscode ist. Es gibt immer diese schöne Sache, wenn das ganze Haus dann so verkabelt ist und dann kommt man nur noch mit Passwort und Gesichtserkennung ins Haus rein. Ja, und was passiert dann, wenn der Sohn plötzlich mit dem Skateboard auf der Straße auf die Nase fliegt, verheult, blutend, schmutzig vor der Tür steht?
Ja, dann ist dann nämlich Schluss. Und dann heißt es leider immer doch den Schlüssel, so als Notreserve, und dann ist alles wieder für die Füße.
Wenn es die Schlüssel dann noch gibt.
Ja, wenn es die Schlüssel dann noch gibt.
Das ist ein großes Problem. Also eigentlich alle biometrischen Verfahren haben den Nachteil, dass es manche Leute gibt, für die sie einfach nicht funktionieren. Also sei es weil sie keinen Finger haben oder keine Augen haben oder weil sie einfach so ein komisches Gesicht haben, dass die Software damit nicht klarkommt. Und für die Installation von biometrieverfahrenen großen Einrichtungen ist es zwingend vorgeschrieben, dass es einen zweiten Weg der Authentifizierung gibt, schon aus Gründen der behinderten Förderung und ähnlichen Motiven. Also abschaffen kann man die Schlüssel nicht.
Und dann kommen natürlich so Dinge dazu. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das schon erwähnt hatten, dass Kinder und besonders alte Menschen Probleme haben mit bestimmten biometrischen Systemen. Schwarze oder Menschen anderer Hautfarbe, da funktionieren manche Systeme nicht so gut. Und manche Systeme...
Sie haben aber das Problem, dass sie das nicht bedienen wollen und nicht bedienen können und Angst davor haben.
Nein, das Problem ist, dass dadurch die Schwelle wieder... Dass man die Schwelle dann anders wählen muss und dass die Menschen einfach sehr verschieden sind. Oder noch eine Sache ist halt Männer und Frauen. Da haben die Systeme auch gewisse Probleme. Manche funktionieren halt bei Männern besser, manche bei Frauen.
Aber du hattest ja...
Die Akzeptanz ist auch ein großes Problem. Also Leute sind halt verschiedenwillig, verschiedene Körperteile in verschiedene Öffnungen in der Wand reinzustecken. Es ist schon ein Unterschied, ob man in eine Kamera guckt, ob man seinen Fingerabdruck abgibt oder ob sie einem mit einer 200 Watt Halogenleuchte direkt auf den Augenhintergrund leuchten. Sicherlich ist das ein wichtiger Aspekt, wollen denn das die Leute überhaupt.
Und was bringt das und vor allem wozu führt das am Ende? Weil selbst wenn ich mich daran gewöhnt habe, dass ich meinen Computer damit, mich einlogge, dass ich mein Fingerchen darauf patsche, dann geht das vielleicht nicht. Die zweite Möglichkeit war die mit dem Passwort. Aber das habe ich jetzt echt vergessen nach einem Dreivierteljahr. Wie war denn das? Ich habe das ja ein Dreivierteljahr nicht benutzt. Und nun weiß ich das auch nicht mehr. Da fangen die Probleme an. Aber du warst eigentlich bei einem anderen Aspekt. Nämlich ganz zu Anfang sagtest du, man muss dann halt den Techniker kennen, der das wartet. Ein interessanter Side-Effekt davon wäre, man muss vielleicht gar nicht den Techniker kennen. Vielleicht reicht es einfach schon zu wissen, wo das Kabel langgeht. Weil man muss ja nicht unbedingt zwangsweise die physikalischen Eigenschaften simulieren, die jetzt der Sensor, welcher auch immer das ist, aufnimmt, sondern möglicherweise, es ist ja auch clever und interessant, auf dem Kabelweg, also da wo die Signale zum Rechner, zum Computer übertragen werden, einzusteigen und einfach die Signale zu simulieren, die das Gerät geben würde.
Das funktioniert aber bei Systemen mit zweifachem Schlüssel auf alle Fälle nicht, wo die Schlüssel ja nicht vollständig ausgeteilt werden.
Was ist ein System mit zweifachem Schlüssel?
Ja zum Beispiel irgendeine Secure Shell.
Wir reden ja jetzt von Biometrie.
Die Datenübertragung ist dieselbe.
Man kann theoretisch so Sachen machen, dass man sagt, man nimmt hier ein tamperproof Device und handelt da einen Session Key aus. Aber in der Praxis wird das nicht getan. Also wenn man sich die existierenden Systeme anguckt, da kommt entweder ein Videokabel raus oder es kommt USB raus. Und die wenigsten Geräte sind gegen Replay-Attacken sicher.
Also du hast natürlich recht. Prinzipiell würde man sich das, wenn man es denn schon macht, auch wünschen, dass da tatsächlich für Schlüssel die Daten auf der Leitung langgehen. Und möglicherweise, dass die Authentifizierung im Device selbst stattfindet, also auf der Hardware-Ebene des Gerätes selbst und dass die Information, ob das jetzt in Ordnung war oder nicht, über das Kabel übertragen wird und zwar auf den Schlüssel.
Frage noch, was wirst du denn tun, wenn du aufgefordert wirst, deinen Fingerabdruck beim Amt zu hinterlassen, wenn du einen neuen Personalausweis beantragst? Wirst du das zähneknirschend hinnehmen und dahin gehen oder hast du dir darüber schon mal Gedanken gemacht?
Ich werde es wohl oder übel zähneknirschend hinnehmen müssen. Das Problem ist ein anderes, dass ich natürlich jetzt erstmal sehe, es zu vermeiden, so lange wie möglich aufs Amt zu gehen.
Das ist ein guter Hinweis, jetzt ist ein guter Zeitpunkt, einen neuen Personalausweis oder Pass zu beantragen, weil nämlich jetzt die neuen Sicherheitsmerkmale, Klammer auf Hologramme schon drin sind. Fingerabdruck oder Handgeometrie oder was immer sie sich ausdenken, aber noch nicht und damit kann man schon mal den nächsten 10 Jahre überleben, ohne dass man noch mehr hinrin ist.
Handgeometrie auf so einem kleinen Ausweis? Sie haben aber kleine Hände.
Das sind ja nur die Zahlen.
Das ist übrigens noch so ein Problem, dass dann plötzlich auf meinem Ausweis Zahlen stehen, die ich nicht mehr nachvollziehen kann. Also eigentlich habe ich ja, sagen wir mal, einen moralischen Anspruch darauf zu wissen, was auf diesem Dokument über mich steht.
Ist ja heute schon nicht so. Ich habe da meine Ausweisnummer drauf und weißt du, was da in der Datenbank steht?
Ich weiß, was auf dem Ausweis steht, wenn irgendjemand meinen Ausweis hat. Wenn das nicht die Leute mit zu auf die Datenbank sind, weiß ich, was die für mich wissen und was nicht.
Ich behaupte mal ganz ketzerisch, dass du keine Ahnung hast, für was dieser kleine Haken unten rechts ist.
Was für ein kleiner Haken unten rechts ist?
Ja, guck doch mal auf deinen Ausweis.
Ich gucke jetzt auf meinen Ausweis. Spannung heute Abend dem Blumen-Muner-Fritz. Wo ist denn der kleine Haken? Der kleine, das von, von von Malotki. Meinst du den Haken?
Ich rede von irgendeinem beliebigen kleinen Haken, der auf manchen aufweisen, drauf ist und auf manchen nicht. Und ihr habt keine Ahnung, wofür der gut ist. Ich weiß das ehrlich gestanden auch nicht. Aber wer kann das auch wissen? Da sind auch mit Verlaub auf diesem Aus...
Aber das wissen auch die Leute, die es kontrollieren, nicht?
Bist du sicher, dass das alle nicht wissen? Oder weißt du, was, wer, wovon weißt? Wir kennen das gleiche Beispiel von Krankenkassenkarten, wo dann halt irgendwelche... Ob das jetzt Zahlenkolonnen sind, oder ob der Ausweis halt irgendein anderes Element enthält, das irgendetwas für dich aussagt.
Ich hab keinen kleinen Haken.
Ja, sei mal froh.
Ich habe aber, das finde ich ja mal besonders toll, wer das mal hinten auf seinem Ausweis kontrollieren möchte, um wieder Verschwörungstheorien mit dem Spiel zu bringen, auf dem ich hier stehe. Auf dem Hintergrund sieht man ja einen Teufelskopf-Munkel, mit einem Auge, das finde ich ja toll. Das stelle ich immer wieder fest, mit Hörnern und allem. Muss man sich mal angucken.
Aha, habe ich auch was von den Drogen kriegen?
Guck mal, das sieht man auch ganz deutlich, mit Hörnern und mit dem Schnau... also quasi diesen Kopf, so eine Art von Schädel.
Aber man muss den verkehrt umhalten und von ein bisschen weiter hingucken.
Du hast recht.
Oh ja, das hier sieht gemein aus.
Da sind auch drei Sechsen, hat das was zu bedeuten?
Doch, das ist irrelevant.
Ich sehe da eher einen Stierkopf.
Was ist das?
Ja, aber wir nehmen das als Teufel, weil er nur ein Auge hat. Ich meine, man muss improvisieren. Auf jeden Fall. So, kurzer Seufzer meinerseits. Ihr wisst wirklich nicht, was der kleine Haken zu bedeuten hat oder behaltet ihr euch das vor?
Hey, ich hab die kleinen Haken gerade eben erfunden. Es geht lediglich darum, dass man das halt nicht wissen kann, okay?
Steini erschreckt kleine Kinder.
Mit dieser Krankenkassenkarte übrigens, ist das was, wo diese biometrischen Sachen auch irgendwann Einzug halten werden, was meint ihr? Weil gerade da auch mit Medikamenten, weil da kann man jemanden ja auch relativ gut identifizieren, was für Drogen er im Blut hat, was für Medikamente er benutzt regelmäßig, sowas.
Es gibt in dieser medizinischen Diagnose-Code Datenbank auch einen vierstelligen Code für ist schwul oder ähnliche Sachen. Also da werden ganz merkwürdige Sachen gespeichert. Und die reden natürlich die ganze Zeit über zentrale Datenbanken, sodass jeder Arzt jederzeit an alle Unterlagen rankommt. Das war ja alles nur zum Wohle des Patienten.
Ich muss noch mal zum Ausweis zurück, ganz hinten, als letztes steht bei mir, da kommen drei lange Zahlen, die ich alle drei nicht verstehe. Und als letztes kommt eine 2.
Du hast eine 2? Ich hab eine 6.
Du, Steini, wenn du die mittlere Zahl nicht verstehst, dann weiß ich auch nicht. Und das ganz hinten ist eine Prüfziffer und jeweils letzte Zahl.
Aber was sagt denn von der mittleren Zahl die hinterste Zahl?
Das ist die Prüfziffer.
Das ist die Prüfziffer, okay. Und die 2 hinten am Ende?
Das ist auch eine Prüfziffer, noch mal über das Gesamte.
Und die sagt jetzt gerade oder ungerade?
Ne, da wird ein Muster drauf multipliziert. Also die erste Stelle mit 7, die zweite Stelle mit 3.
Ich gucke hier gerade aufs Pult.
Auf dem Pult steht die Zahl 2330. Die Zahl verstehe ich 2330. Wir machen mal eben Nachrichten.
Dann 101, 5.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Mit dem Wetter nachts wolkig und trocken, 4 bis 1 Grad. Tag verbreitet Regen, 4 bis 7 Grad. Jetzt die Meldungen mit Gerald Kötter-Heinrich.
Die Bundesregierung warnte heute nachdrücklich davor, den Antiterror-Krieg auf andere Länder als Afghanistan auszuweiten. Bundeskanzler Schröder und Außenminister Fischer riefen zur Besonnenheit auf. Die Nordallianz hat offenbar ihren Widerstand gegen eine internationale Friedenstruppe in Afghanistan aufgegeben. Auf der Konferenz in Bonn hieß es, das Nordbündnis könne ohne Soldaten akzeptieren, solange diese im Rahmen eines Friedensabkommen stationiert würden. In Berlin haben sich SPD, Grüne und FDP bei ihren Koalitionsgesprächen auf Einsparungen in den Bereichen Schule und Sport geeinigt. In der Frage der Olympiabewerbung für 2012 waren sie sich noch uneins. Die Berliner Grünen haben ein prominentes Gründungsmitglied verloren. Wie die Berliner Zeitung berichtet, trat Elmar Altvater, Professor an der Freien Universität, aus Protest gegen den Krieg in Afghanistan aus der Partei aus. In der Nähe von Augsburg ist am Abend ein Kleinflugzeug abgestürzt. Alle vier Insassen kamen ums Leben. Zum Fußball der 1. FC Union Berlin hat die nächste Runde des DFB Pokals erreicht. Der Zweitligist siegte beim Verbandsligisten SSV Ulm mit 3 zu 0. Und das Champions League Spiel zwischen Juventus Turin und Bayer Leverkusen ist zum zweiten Mal wegen Nebels abgesagt worden. Neuansetzung dritter Versuch übrigens morgen 15 Uhr. Verkehr A12 Richtung Frankfurt oder an der Grenze zu Polen gibt es Stau.
Berühmt für seine Bekanntheit. Donnerstag 13. Dezember in der Columbia Halle.
Exakt, wir haben die Halbzeit erreicht. 1, 5 Stunden gibt es noch vom Chaosradio mit dem Chaos Computer Club zu Gast im Studio. Mein Name ist Max von Malotki, zu Gast weiterhin der Steini, der Andreas und der Pawel. Und am Telefon zum Thema Biometrie hat angerufen, das könnt ihr weiterhin tun unter 033 177 97 110, hat der Marcel aus Magdeburg, Name Marcel. Er möchte stimmlich wahrscheinlich nicht erkannt werden, bei all den Identifikationsverfahren und Authentifizierungsverfahren, die wir heute vorgestellt haben. Das heißt, er sagt nichts, aber Marcel hat auch lange gewartet, das muss man zugestehen. Probieren wir es mal mit dem Dave. Hallo Dave.
Ja, ich wollte mal eine heiße Story anbringen. Und zwar ist die vom Landeskriminalamt zu der ganzen Panikmache von wegen der Datenspeicherung und Identifizierung. Ich habe letztens eine Mail bekommen, die mich zum Betrug aufgefordert hat von einem Wachsdirektor aus Afrika, für den ich 14 Millionen US-Dollar waschen sollte. Dann kam ich auf die Idee, ich ruf einfach mal die Bullerei an, 110, wurde dann durchgestellt und landete schließlich beim Landeskriminalamt LKA Abteilung Betrug. Und hab dem Herrn nochmal die Story geschildert. Und dann sagte er, ja, so was verfolgen sie eigentlich nicht weiter, da haben sie gar nicht die Mittel dazu. Aber wenn ich gerne möchte, kann ich das ja mal ausdrucken und Ihnen schicken. Und dann sagte ich zu ihm, ich kann ihm ja einfach die Mail weiterleiten. Und dann kam die Antwort, Herr Müller, es tut mir leid, aber wir haben hier bei uns im Zimmer überhaupt keinen Computer zu stehen. Und dann war ich erstmal sprachlos. Und dann ist mir eigentlich klar geworden, dass das doch ziemlich viel Panikmache ist oder nicht. Wenn die Betrugsabteilung vom Landeskriminalamt noch nie mal einen Computer da oben zu stehen hat. Soll ich die mal sagen? Ich glaube, er ist sich sehr sicher, wenn er in Pension geht, wird da immer noch kein Computer stehen. Also dann frage ich, wer soll denn dann die ganzen Biometriedaten speichern?
Da gespeichert werden die Zentral- und Terminals zur Abfrage der Datenbanken, also der Inpol-Datenbank. Zum Beispiel haben die natürlich. Die haben da halt keinen PC rumzustehen, mit dem sie mehr empfangen können. Sehe ich natürlich, dass das die Polizei bei ihrer Arbeit behindert, was nicht gut ist und die Sicherheit in diesem Lande nicht verbessert. Aber das hält natürlich zum Beispiel das BKA nicht davon ab, eine Zentral-Datenbank zu führen oder den Bundesverfassungsschutz oder den Bundesnachrichtendienst oder was ist da sonst noch an Behörden und Organisationen mit Sicherheitsaufgaben?
Im Übrigen ist auch Betrug an dieser Stelle gar nicht das Thema, wo es dann so in erster Linie um diese biometrischen Verfahren geht, über die wir gerade sprechen. Das heißt, das kann schon sein, dass die sagen, ja, schöne Sache, erstens glaube ich, nehmen sie das nicht ganz ernst, weil das erste, was ich mir frage, wieso kommt irgendein Mensch, den du nicht kennst, auf die Idee, dich zu bitten, dir wie viele Millionen...
Ja, aber ich habe auch so eine Mail gekriegt, glaube ich, gerade gestern, die ist, glaube ich, die haben irgendwie was auf einem Massenmailer. Außerdem ist davon mehrfach in der Presse berichtet worden, von der Geschichte schon. Nigeria ist das, glaube ich, gewesen, nicht wahr?
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist nicht ernst zu nehmen.
Nein, nein, es ist so, dass da tatsächlich Leute drauf reingefallen sind, die sind dann nach Nigeria eingeladen worden, in Regierungsgebäuden tatsächlich bewirtet und empfangen worden. Also da hängt halt die Regierung mit drin und denen ist dann halt eine ganze Menge Geld aus der Tasche gezogen worden, auf die Art und Weise, und jetzt ist das wahrscheinlich durch. Jetzt versuchen sie es nochmal mit Massenmailing, aber das ist halt wohl eine recht bekannte Masche, wo sie Millionen teilweise bereits einzelnen Leuten abgezogen haben.
Ja, super coole Geschichten.
Das einzige, was ich damit irgendwo mal ein bisschen zeigen wollte, ist, das kann schon sein, das Bundeskriminalamt, da werden Bereiche recht gut ausgestattet sein, oder der Verfassungsschutz, aber darunter hört das dann offensichtlich auch schon aus.
Ja, das ist in der Tat so, dass an manchen Stellen, auch für mein Gefühl, es dann etwas übertrieben wird, beispielsweise wenn man von Amt zu Amt rennen muss mit irgendwelchen Zettelchen, weil die einfach nicht in der Lage sind, untereinander Daten auszutauschen oder keine Rechner haben oder das nicht dürfen. Da in der Tat, sage ich mal, hätte ich keine Probleme mit, wenn da an manchen Stellen einfach die Arbeit ein bisschen effizienter laufen würde. Und gerade deswegen ist es, ich meine, du hast natürlich recht, es ist ziemlich vermessen, jetzt von Biometrie zu reden, wo man vielleicht den Schritt zwei und drei vor dem Schritt vier oder fünf, den die Biometrie eigentlich darstellt, noch gar nicht gemacht hat.
Ja, es ist wahrscheinlich einfach nur, wie ihr schon gesagt habt, um die Leute ruhig zu stellen unter dem Motto, es passiert was, und eure Sicherheit wird immer größer. Aber dass noch nicht mal ein Polizist da irgendwo irgendwie einen Computer hat, um mit diesen Daten überhaupt umzugehen...
Das ändert doch aber nichts daran, dass da ein Bedrohungspotenzial geschaffen wird. Also über die Geruchsdatenbanken der Stasi haben sich alle aufgeregt, da kann ich mich noch gut dran erinnern. Und wenn jetzt Gendatenbanken aufgebaut werden, die eigentlich genau dasselbe sind, dann ist das plötzlich die normalste Sache der Welt und das verstehe ich nicht.
Außerdem wird wahrscheinlich, wenn die Dinge, also da, wo die Sachen zuerst ablaufen werden oder geprüft werden, werden möglicherweise sogar private Firmen, wie jetzt am Flughafen, die Sicherheitsüberprüfung übernehmen und da wird das dann halt schon funktionieren. Aber es ist in der Tat richtig, dass wenn man sich fragt, also wenn die Regierung 1000 Mark hat für die Terrorbekämpfung, wo sie die am besten investieren sollte, dann ist das mit Sicherheit nicht die Biometrie, wo die 1000 Mark am besten untergebracht sind. Das zeigt glaube ich deine Geschichte schon ganz anschaulich.
Ich denke aber, was wir erleben werden, wenn das tatsächlich kommt, und das ist alles andere als sicher, das finde ich auch erstmal gut so, aber was wir erleben werden ist, dass du dann tatsächlich Werbung ins Haus kriegst, die dir Anti-Falten-Creme empfiehlt, nur weil du irgendwo in deinem Gesichtserkennner bei irgendeinem Kaufhaus durchgelaufen bist, um damit zu bezahlen. Solche Dinge werden wir dann erleben. Und die werden dann, was weiß ich, nachdem du deinen Finger in irgendein ominöses Gerät gehalten hast, wird dir danach irgendwie eine Aufforderung von deinem Arzt kommen. Du müsstest doch mal wieder wegen deinem Blutzugesspiegel vorbeikommen.
Sie haben Krebs, kommen sie doch mal vorbei.
Eine nette Sache ist ja auch ein bisschen absurd an dieser Diskussion, gerade um die biometrischen Merkmale im deutschen Personalausweis ausgerechnet. Weil, also erstens wüsste ich nicht, also hatte einer, also gerade die Leute, von denen ja eigentlich das höchste Bedrohungspotenzial vermutlich ausgeht, haben gar keinen deutschen Personalausweis. Damit fängt es schon mal an. Die Amerikaner sind da ein bisschen cleverer. Die haben ja auch überhaupt keinen Personalausweis. Die denken darüber nach, Biometrien nur für Ausländer zu verlangen. Das heißt, wenn du demnächst in die USA einreist, wird dir dann halt bei der Einreise der Fingerabdruck abgeladen.
Weil alle Amerikaner sind gut.
Weil die Amerikaner ja gut, aber das ist zumindest, ich sag mal sicherlich politisch eher durchzusetzen, als das, was jetzt, ja, die Diskussion, die eigentlich hier geführt wurde. Und dazu kommt noch, und das sagen auch, soweit ich weiß, alle offiziellen Experten wie Datenschützer oder Kriminologen, dass die Identitätsfeststellung in Deutschland eigentlich kein Problem ist. Das ist in Deutschland bereits besser gelöst als in allen anderen Ländern. Deswegen, ja.
Ja, in Großbritannien überhaupt nicht denkbar, so was. Also völlig undenkbar. Da haben sie zwar 30.000 Kameras, aber es gibt keine Pflicht, einen Person in der Tasche zu tragen.
Ja, und jedes Land hat da natürlich so auch seine Besonderheiten. In den USA wieder gibt es auch keinen Personalausweis. Dafür haben die halt keinen Datenschutz. Und es gibt eben tausend Daten über dich, die irgendwo gespeichert sind, die dich wieder anders definieren. Aber problematisch ist natürlich, wenn das dann alles, was es irgendwo auf der Welt gibt, irgendwo kombiniert wird. Also Personalausweis plus tausende von Datenbanken plus Kameras, ich glaube, in so einem Land wird es dann langsam unspaßig.
Irgendwie ist echt wahr. Warum habe ich nur das Gefühl, dass ausgerechnet das so abartig typisch Deutsch ist? Und warum stört mich ausgerechnet daran auch noch, dass ausgerechnet der Otto Schily so in dieses Horn tutet? Also ein Ex-RAV-Anwalt, das will mir nicht ins Hirn. Das kapiere ich einfach. Das muss mir mal echt jemand erklären.
Vielleicht gerade deshalb.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Sie tatsächlich glauben, dass man das Gefühl hat, dass das jetzt Sicherheit gegen Terroristen bringt. Ich meine, es ist völlig offensichtlich, um was es hier geht. Es geht darum, die Leute, die hier in diesem Land leben, einfach besser im Griff zu behalten. Ich will da nicht mal Böswilligkeit unterstellen. Ich will nur unterstellen, dass es einfach irgendwie eine deutsche Mentalität ist, bloß am liebsten alles wissen zu wollen.
Ich meine, er hat natürlich mit dem Ganzen absolut der CDU-CSU die Lufthoheit über den Stammtischen einmalig abgerufen. Die haben wirklich nur fassungslos dargestanden und wussten nun überhaupt nicht, was sie mehr oder weniger fordern sollten an dieser Stelle.
Ich glaube, wir haben unseren Hörer verloren.
Nicht wirklich. Ich denke mal, er ist noch im Auto unterwegs, aber der Blinker, der blinkte die ganze Zeit und irgendwann muss man noch weiterfahren. Danke, Dave, für den Fall, dass du uns noch zuhörst. Wollen wir denn direkt jemand Neues dranlassen? Ich fand irgendwie die Begründung, was Schily anbelangt, vorhin besser, dass der einfach sich politisch profilieren muss und irgendwas machen muss.
Der Kanzler war ihm bestimmt hoch dankbar dafür. Ich habe mich auch nachträglich ein bisschen beruhigt, muss ich ja sagen, als ich gesehen habe, dass da doch wirklich viel mehr Rauch als Feuer am Ende gewesen ist, aber ein komisches Gefühl bleibt, weil ich fürchte fast, dass er das geglaubt hat, was er gesagt hat.
Tun Politiker das in der Regel?
Na ja, das tun sie, damit sie sich nicht als schlechte Menschen fühlen müssen, was zu den üblichen Phänomenen von Schizophrenie und Paranoia führt, die man bei manchen Politikern beobachten kann, wenn sie sich auf der Kamera stehen und schwitzen.
Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, für den Fall Schily wird gewusst haben, dass er bestimmte Sachen nicht durchsetzen kann, von der Meinung des Volkes her, von der politischen Meinung her und von der technischen Entwicklung her. Das heißt, er kann einfach sagen, pass mal auf Kollegen, wir machen das, ist das nicht geil, bin ich nicht cool, alle sagen Bravo oder sagen alle, es geht nicht.
Ich glaube aber, so war es nicht. Wir können natürlich viel spekulieren, aber wenn ich ihn vor der Kamera gesehen habe, ich glaube, der war wirklich so geschockt und hatte wirklich demgegen so der Arsch auf Grundeis. Ich meine, es war glaube ich wirklich eine Situation. Ich meine, er ist ja dann auch gleich nach Amerika gefahren und ist da noch ordentlich bearbeitet worden von den Amerikanern, die ihm dann auch noch erzählt haben, wie furchtbar und schrecklich das alles ist mit den Terroristen. Und ich glaube, der hatte einfach wirklich Angst. Das ist meine Vermutung.
Meinst du eine Übersprungsreaktion?
Ja, wie auch immer. Ich meine, er ist ja auch nur ein Mensch. Der war nicht cool. In dem Moment. Und deswegen meine ich, der hat das nicht irgendwie gespielt.
Aber ich meine, was da alles schief geht, so emotional bei Leuten, merkt man jetzt auch gerade deutlich an den Grünen. Ich meine, da passieren einfach Sachen. Das ist schon verrückt. Aber wir kommen ein bisschen vom Thema ab.
Wir werden uns einfach auf die Spür zurückführen lassen von den Hörern, die auch weiter anrufen können. 033 177 97 110 ist die Nummer. Und ich hoffe Hartmut aus Steglitz, Berlin. Steglitz ist noch am Telefon.
Also ich denke, dass sie sich die Biometrie durchsetzen will. Und ich habe sie noch gar nicht gesprochen hier. Die ist im Anfangsstadium, also technologisch gesehen. Das ist so ähnlich wie beim PC, vielleicht die XT-Zeit oder so.
Seit 20 Jahren ist die im Anfangsstadium mindestens. Und ja, das ist richtig. Du hast natürlich damit Recht, dass die Geräte besser werden. Und auch die Untersuchungen, die durchgeführt werden, zeigen tatsächlich, dass die Qualität der Geräte besser wird. Aber es ist auch abzusehen, dass die Geräte niemals perfekt werden werden. Das heißt, es wird irgendwann konvergieren. Und irgendwann wird es einfach nicht mehr besser werden.
Ich betrachte das einfach so, dass es so ähnlich wie ein Schlüssel, wenn ich einen ganz normalen Haustierschlüssel habe, und ich mache einfach nur die Haustür zu, dann ist es auch etwas anders. Und der Banksafe ist viel anders gesichert. Das heißt, es hat im Prinzip auch einen Schlüssel. Und so ist es im Prinzip genauso. Aber ihr sagt immer, man kann irgendwie alles knacken. Jedes abgestattene Haus kann knacken. Ich kann nicht sagen, ich treibe so einen riesen Aufwand, denn kostet mir nur die Wohnungssicherung eine Million. Dann sage ich einfach, es ist mehr wert als meine ganze Einrichtung, sollen sie die ruhig zweimal im Jahr klauen, ist immer noch weniger.
Aber was du berücksichtigen musst, ist, da gebe ich dir recht, Biometrie hat ihre Berechtigung. Und zwar genau denn, wenn es darum geht, dass mein fiktiver Sohn den Fernseher nicht nach 22 Uhr einschalten kann. Dann macht das schon Sinn. Aber jetzt, wie gesagt, wenn dabei irgendwas geschützt werden soll, was irgendwie einen gewissen Wert hat, dann muss man da aufpassen. Und du hast natürlich auch recht, wenn du sagst, Biometrie entwickelt sich weiter, aber die Technik, um Biometrie zu verarschen und zu umgehen, entwickelt sich genau auch weiter. Was wir hier sehen ist, und das ist in der gesamten Sicherheitstechnik immer der gleiche Fall, die Technologien auf beiden Seiten entwickeln sich weiter, man lernt voneinander und es wird immer komplexer. Damit wird möglicherweise die Menge an Leuten, die jemand umgehen können, für den Anfang auch komplexer, aber das ist eine Pyramide nach unten.
Da hast du natürlich vollkommen recht, das ist vollkommen klar. Ich mein, das ist ja, muss man einfach betrachten, wie ganz normaler Diebstahl. Vor 20 Jahren gab es auch keine Warndiebstahl oder Warnanrichtungen im Auto. Dann haben die Autodiebstähle zugenommen, und das ist auch eine Sparer, da gibt es wieder welche, die können knacken. Ich bin nur ein Beispiel, ich arbeite als Berater und bin in so vielen Firmen, und das ist einfach so ein Aufwand, immer was die dort treiben. Da wäre das einfach so relativ einfach irgendwo. Ich habe Missbrauch alleine wenig erlebt. Der größte Missbrauch ist, in 80% der Fällen wird von Leuten verursacht, die Zugang haben und verautorisiert Zugang haben. Das muss man einfach mal betrachten. Wir haben auch schon mal Kreditkarten, alles Mögliche gekauft. Da sagt man einfach, Schwund, 3%, 5% ist okay. Bei sich heiterelevanten Daten a la Schily ist das natürlich etwas ganz anderes, würde ich sagen. Aber da kommt es auch vor. Genauso können sie mich einfach festnehmen und sagen, ich habe auch schon in U-Haft gesessen für 24 Stunden und so weiter. Ich sage einfach mal, irgendwann muss ich damit leben, weil wir ein System nehmen, die nie perfekt sein werden. Und selbst die Stasi, weil die so oft angesprochen haben, die haben so eine Menge Daten gehabt, genauso wie viele Unternehmen, Kunden- und Unternehmensdaten haben, und die blicken einfach nicht mehr durch, weil sie wirklich viel zu viel haben. Und das, was sie brauchen, haben sie nicht mehr.
Weil sie keine Computer hatten, sie hatten Computer aber nicht, wo alle Daten drin waren. Also das ist heute schon was anderes.
Ich arbeite gerade in diesem ERP-Bereich und die Leute blicken in 90% der Felder nicht durch.
In welchem Bereich bitte?
Also Leuten was beibringst du zu sagen.
Oder da kommt dann natürlich, also wenn die Leute nicht durchblicken, ist es natürlich noch umso schlimmer. Und insbesondere kriegen sie sie nicht weg oder gelöscht oder verändert. Ich meine, jeder von uns kennt sicherlich auch immer wieder die immer wieder auftretenden Probleme. Man will irgendetwas und dann erzählt einem das Gegenüber am Telefon, der Computer hat dieses oder jenes nicht so gemacht oder macht das nicht oder nimmt meine Eingabe nicht an.
Vollkommen richtig.
Und wenn man da jetzt natürlich sich jetzt noch die Biometrie irgendwo dran denkt, dann wird das glaube ich alles nicht besser. Genau.
Was ist die Alternative?
Na, keine Biometrie. Was genau soll die Biometrie kriegen?
Ja, ich meine jetzt diese vielen Passwörter. Ich habe dann auch irgendwann so viele, blicke ich irgendwo nicht mehr durch. Da habe ich alles drin gehabt, damit ich überhaupt noch durchblicke.
Die Frage, wenn du nach der Alternative fragst, musst du immer sagen, in welchem Fall. Also Biometrie ist nicht richtig pauschal verkehrt, sondern Biometrie ist einfach für ganz viele Sachen, für die sie heute eingesetzt werden will und eingesetzt werden soll, hoch ungeeignet. Und bestimmte Verfahren dieser Biometrie sind ganz besonders ungeeignet.
Also eine sehr schöne Kombination jetzt für die Art von, also für Authentifizierungsprobleme finde ich jetzt. Also pragmatisch ist eine Kombination aus einer eigenen Chipkarte und einem Kennwort, wo halt ich nur über das Kennwortzugang zu dem Chipkarteninhalt habe und wo es meine Chipkarte ist, wo und mit der halt entsprechend kryptographisch gesichert kommuniziert wird. Zum Beispiel also fürs Banking beispielsweise ist das die angenehmste Variante, also wesentlich besser als Tanz. Und genau dasselbe halt, wenn ich Zugang zu irgendwelchen Systemen habe, wichtig dabei ist, dass das Ganze eben meine Karte ist und ich die Verfügung über diese Karte habe.
Genau, ich habe in diesen Sicherheitszahlen, ich habe zum Beispiel auch, von der Swiss Addys jetzt gar nicht mehr, gibt es auch solche Karten als Zielflieger und von der Lufthansa auch. Das heißt, ich komme in bestimmten Flughäfen einfach rein mit meiner Karte. Klaut mir der jemand, dann geht der einfach durch. Manchmal gucken die gar nicht mehr zu ausweiten, ist eh ein Fehlflieger, die gehen einfach durch. Das heißt, ich werde teilweise noch nicht mal kontrolliert. Durch ganz separate Eingänge komme ich einfach durch und das hat man auch jetzt bei den Anstehungen am 11. gesehen, die sind da auch einfach durchgegangen, durch alle Kontrollen durchgekommen. Und mit der Karte, die ich habe, ist das überhaupt kein Problem, den ziehe ich durch einen Schlitz durch und wenn mir der einer klaut, der geht in einigen Flughäfen, geht der einfach durch. Das heißt, die Leute, da kann ich auch irgendeinen Waschzetteln hinhalten anstatt einen Ausweis. Das sehen die so gar nicht genau.
Und dann stell dir erstmal vor, du hast halt irgendwie einen VIP-Fingerabdruck auf deinem Daumen kleben.
Hey, das ist LL Cool J, aber er ist so blass.
Also du merkst schon, worauf das rausläuft, die Methodik. Wenn du jetzt diese Verfahren an der Stelle verbesserst, wird das Vertrauen in diese Verfahren immer größer. Wenn aber die Sicherheit dadurch gar nicht verbessert wird, weil dir so eine Karte zu klauen, sollte nicht viel schwerer sein, als dir auch dein Fingerabdruck zu klauen. Das ist ein klein bisschen mehr Aufwand, das geben wir ja zu. Da wollen wir ja auch gar nicht so sein. Aber der Aufwand ist nicht besonders groß, nicht besonders viel größer. Dafür ist aber das Vertrauen der anderen, dass jetzt da ja auch ein Fingerabdruck dabei ist, dann so, dass da nicht mal mehr einer steht, der noch guckt, weil es war ja die Karte richtig und der Fingerabdruck auch. Und irgendwann wird der Mensch, der die Endkontrolle macht, abgeschafft, weil es billiger ist. Und dann haben wir nämlich die Kake richtig am Dampfen.
Ja, also es ist, wie gesagt, für bestimmte Sicherheitsbereiche oder Bereiche im Unternehmen macht Biometrie als zusätzliche Sicherheitsmaßnahme durchaus Sinn. Bei übersichtlichen Benutzergruppen, so von einigen hundert oder vielleicht maximal ein paar tausend Leuten, denke ich, gibt es durchaus praktikable Kombinationen. Aber irgendwie zu versuchen, ein Volk mit 80 Millionen Menschen irgendwo biometrisch zu erfassen, das ist einfach sinnlos, wird nicht funktionieren und es ist einfach...
Ich glaube, das steckt auch gar nicht dahinter jetzt politisch, weil ihr sagt, oh, die wollen da alles so genau selektieren, keine Fälschung mehr. Was sie einfach machen wollen, die kriegen einfach raus. Ich mache ein ganz simpler Fehler. Die sagen mir einfach, was sie so gar nicht sagen, aha, beantragt eine Firma wieder Atta oder dreimal soziale Hilfe. Die filtern einfach raus, der hat einen ungeheuren Aufwand, kann auch machen. Aber es ist diese 80-20-Regel. 80 Prozent fallen einfach durch und die anderen 20 machen sich den Aufwand und haben dann auch natürlich genauso ihren Gewinn. Ich sag, die wird man noch gar nicht packen, vollkommen klar. Aber die große Masse, das ist wie beim Haustisch, das schließt sich ab, dann würde ich so aufstehen oder auflassen einfach. Dann werden jeden Tag irgendwelche Leute in der Wohnung. Und so ist der Aufwand einfach größer, obwohl man mit einem Schaubenzieher die Wohnung knacken kann.
Ja, aber ich behaupte mal, dass die, ob es 80-20-95-5 sind, ist ja gerade egal. Aber ich glaube, dass diese 5 Prozent immer die gleichen sind. Also das wird sich dadurch nichts ändern, das wird nur auf eine neue Stufe gehoben. Es wird dadurch nicht mehr oder nicht weniger krimineller oder Institutionen geben, die an sowas interessiert sind oder Leute, die das missbrauchen. Die Anzahl wird identisch bleiben, weil der Aufwand war schon immer gleich.
Und wenn man mal so eine Schadennutzensbilanz zieht, dann kann ich an vielen Stellen nur Schaden sehen. Also auf der Nutzenseite sehe ich eigentlich keinen Nutzen, außer dass vielleicht ein paar Leute beruhigt werden durch das Reden darüber. Also es ist sicherlich eine sicherheitsrhetorische, ganz geeignete Maßnahme. Auf der Schadensseite sehe ich zunächst mal, dass das Geld, was da an der Stelle investiert wird, an anderer Stelle fehlt. Das ist schon mal Schaden Nummer eins. Dann ein Schaden, über den wir gar nicht geredet haben bisher, ist der Vertrauensschaden, den der Staat mir zufügt an dieser Stelle. Ich fange dann an, misstrauischer zu werden. Das macht mich aggressiv. Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, wenn man die Leute betrachtet, ich erinnere nur an die Volkszählungsdiskussion, das führt dann auch dazu, dass Leute radikalisiert werden, dass Leute, die auf der Grenze stehen, für die das das Fass zum Überlaufen bringt und die einfach dann beschließen, mit diesem Start muss ich jetzt bekämpfen, mit allen Mitteln. Und damit produzieren wir, ja, und damit produziert...
Der will wieder verteidigen.
Er will wieder von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge und wieder zur alten Linie zurück.
Und damit produziert dann, ich sag mal, produzieren dann solche repressiven Maßnahmen möglicherweise erst die Terroristen, die man dann anschließend damit verfolgen will.
Ich glaube, wenn man einfach sieht, welche Spuren, ich persönlich oder ihr genauso, da hinterlässt fast jeder. Alle, die ein Handy haben oder konnten, und darüber machen, Rasterfahnung ist nichts anderes. Sozialversicherung, überall, Krankenkassen, die haben alle so viel Daten, solange...
Gut, dann brauchen wir ja keine Fingerabdrücke.
Nein, ich meine, die haben jetzt alle Daten, die haben alles Mögliche drauf.
Ja, dann brauchen sie auch nicht noch den Fingerabdruck dazu. Das ist einfach...
Ich betrachte das einfach nicht wegen des Ausweises, ich betrachte dann einfach, den Finger habe ich immer dabei, dann brauchen wir hier nichts anderes. Wenn ich einfach sagen würde, ich würde den Ausweis, alles könnte ich lassen, und ich könnte zu Hause in eine Wohnung einfach mit meinem Finger rein.
Der Mann lebt gefährlich. Du kannst auch ein vierstelliges Zahlenschloss mit vier Zahlen von 0 bis 9 an deine Tür machen. Hey, das geht ein paar Mal gut, und dann macht das platt und dann...
Also du wirst, ich glaube, du wirst keinen Spaß haben mit einem Fingerabdruckschloss an deiner Tür.
Hey, weißt du, deine Karte muss ich klauen. Deinen Fingerabdruck gibst du mir einfach so.
Der ist ein Zweifelsfall auf dem Scanner.
Der ist auf dem Scanner, da ist er...
Hartmut, viel Erfolg beim Restleben, wir treffen uns dann alle in deiner Wohnung. Genau, tschüss erstmal.
Danke, tschüss.
Am Telefon ist nämlich noch der Edwin aus Wilmersdorf, ich hoffe er ist noch dran, Edwin? Hallo, ich komme nämlich gerade aus dem Urlaub. Nicht? Ich komme aus Kolumbien. Ah, ok, ich bin so scharf auf Urlaub, dass ich das immer interpretiere. Der Stand kommt aus Kolumbien, dachte ich, er war in Urlaub, Entschuldige Edwin.
Ja, ich wollte noch dazu sagen, ich habe in meinem Personalausweis einen Fingerabdruck.
Wow, in deinem Kolumbianischen?
Genau.
Und ist der einfach nur gestempelt oder ist der von einem Computer da reingedruckt?
Also, früher war das gestempelt, dann ungefähr vor sieben Jahren mit Computer.
Lass mich raten, die US-Regierung hat nicht unwesentlich dazu beigetragen, das System zu finanzieren, kann das sein?
Upsi, so was aber auch. Jetzt lass mich mal überlegen, warum ausgerechnet Kolumbien? Warte mal, was fällt mir ein bei Kolumbien?
Ich bestoftiere, nee, da hatten sie diesen Krieg, heißt das ja nicht, bewaffnete Auseinandersetzung, andere Ordnung mit...
Mit Kollateralschäden, sonstiger Art.
Ja, wie fühlst du dich denn...
Das sind nur zwei Worte, Plan Kolumbien.
Wie und was hältst du davon?
Also, das heißt, früher hatten wir sowieso schon den Abdruck, dass, keine Ahnung, meine Mutter 67 und wir kriegen Personalausweisungen, wenn man ärgselig ist, und die hatte das schon. Das gibt bei uns seit, ich schätze, 50 Jahre, keine Ahnung. früher gab das so komische Sachen, so wie wenn man so eine Narbe hätte, oder so eine komische Leberflecke, oder so was ganz bestimmtes im Körper.
Das sind unsere Merkmale. Und bist du schon mal, ist denn dein Fingerabdruck schon mal überprüft worden, mit dem Muster auf deinem Personalausweis? Also bist du schon mal in einer Kontrolle gewesen, wo jemand dir deinen Fingerabdruck abgenommen hat und ihn mit dem auf dem Ausweis verglichen hat?
Nein, noch nicht.
Würdest du sagen, dass in Kolumbien die Kriminalität deswegen geringer ist als in Deutschland?
Überhaupt nicht. Von dieser Herst, da kann man alles fällchen. Du kannst da alles kaufen, ein Perso, ein Pass. Wenn du Arzt sein willst, dann kannst du das auch kaufen. Ist alles möglich. Und das ist einfach nicht.
Arzt werden geht in Kolumbien viel schneller als hier. Hier ist ein langer Studienweg.
Die Deutschen sind immer noch ein Entwicklungsland.
Genau.
Und was hältst du von der ganzen Diskussion? Jetzt hier hast du die mitverfolgt um diesen Schily-Katalog und die biometrischen Maßnahmen?
Also ich finde das total äpfel, muss ich sagen. Weil das war, wie einer von euch gesagt hat, sie wollten uns einfach in den Griff haben. So richtig in den Griff. Weil das reicht schon mit so vielen Sachen, die es hier schon gibt. So Anwohnermelder, um das, um das, um das und so weiter und so fort. Zum Beispiel gibt es sowas nicht bei uns. Noch nicht. Ich hoffe, es bleibt auch so. Und noch dazu Fingerabdruck und keine Ahnung, was noch kommt. Ich finde das überhaupt nicht richtig.
Zumal ja gerade die Ausländer von dem Schily-Paket noch in anderer Weise betroffen sind. Zum Beispiel wurde jetzt das Vereinsgesetz geändert. Es gibt jetzt so etwas wie Ausländervereine. Das sind nämlich Vereine, in denen hauptsächlich Ausländer Mitglieder oder Vorstände sind, die dann bestimmten besonderen Regeln unterliegen und so weiter und so fort. Also da hat man sozusagen mal ausgetestet, wie weit man gehen kann. Am Beispiel der Ausländer mit der Überlegung, dass die Lobby da ja nicht so groß sein, weil man sicherlich nicht auf so große Widerstände stößt. Das ist genauso wie bei den Ausreisegesetzen. Da wurden vor zwei oder drei Jahren neue Gesetze verabschiedet. Nachdem diese Hooligan-Prügellei war, bei der ein französischer Polizist schwer verletzt wurde, wurde ein Gesetz eingeführt, das die Reisefreiheit beschränkte. Und mit der Begründung, das würden wir nur gegen Hooligans verwenden. Und dann wurde dasselbe Gesetz gegen Leute eingesetzt, die in Genua demonstrieren wollten und zwar friedlich.
Nein, das wollen wir zum Beispiel in Kolumbien. Ich glaube, das geht auch ganz anders mit jedem Land. Die Gesetze sind ganz verschöner. Bei uns ist es jetzt total streng, hier in ganz Europa einzureisen.
Das muss man sich tatsächlich mal vorstellen. Und dann hast du irgendwo mal deine Finger drauf getatscht. Und vier Wochen später ist da ein Überfall. Und da ist dein dummer Fingerabdruck auf der Glasscheibe von der Banktür. Und dann hast du echt Ärger. Und zwar richtig. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Der dumme Bankräuber hatte auch Handschuhe an. Und den haben sie nicht gekriegt. Und du hast echt Ärger wegen das.
In Schwimmbädern werden ja jetzt Fußabdrücke genommen. Dank dir erstmal, Edwin.
Ich frag mich, was für Körperteile man noch alle wo reindrücken kann.
Die Lippen. Ich hab neulich einen Beitrag gesehen im Fernsehen. Es ging um Gerichtsmedizin, wo ein Bankräuber anhand eines Lippenabdrucks an der Scheibe überführt wurde. Der ist halt beim Rausrennen gegen die Scheibe gerannt.
Nein, was man alles beachten muss.
Der hat es sich als Frau geschminkt. Der war ja gar nicht so doof. Nur, dass er halt irgendwie gegen die Scheibe gerannt ist.
Es ist ja nicht zu fassen. Und das ist durchgegangen, das wundert mich. Da würde ich erstmal eine Studie erwarten, die sagt, dass Lippenabdrücke echt ein gut sind. Ja, krass.
Das Chaosradio am Start am heutigen Abend 5 Minuten nach 12. Wir haben noch eine knappe Stunde. Andreas, Steini und Pawel und Malodki am Start, hier als Host und als Übersetzer im Zweifelsfall und am Telefon nochmal die Grundfrage von Sascha aus Nauköln. Sascha, bist du noch da? Ja, was bringt Biometrie und was ist überhaupt nötig für Biometrie?
Puh, ja, die Frage stelle ich mir auch, weil ich meine, ich denke nur an den Herrn Eduard Zimmermann, müsste euch noch ein Begriff haben. Nein, ich meine jetzt nicht XY.
Okay, so einen weißen Ring?
Nein, ich meine den ehemaligen Innenminister.
Ach, der Innenminister.
Ja, das ist eine Weile her, aber da gab es so eine innige Diskussion mit den händlichen Personen aus dem Wegen Fälschungssicher und so weiter. Die Diskussion ging genau in die Richtung. Es waren zwar keine biometrischen Daten, nur was mich jetzt frage, das war ungefähr vor 20 Jahren, nee, 15 Jahren, da war die große Frage mit der Fälschungssicher aus. Fälschungssicher im Personal, das war schön. Jetzt heißt es plötzlich erst nicht mehr Fälschungssicher. Super geil und das wird irgendwie, denke ich, mehr in fünf Jahren ist auch der jetzige, sind die biometrischen Daten nicht mehr fälschungssicher, oder die sind jetzt schon nicht mehr fälschungssicher, was soll das? Ich meine, der Punkt ist der, Terrorismus hat sich nicht geändert, der ist immer noch da. Verbrechen, Kriminalität ist noch genauso da. Ich meine, wenn ich überlege, dass ich bei einer Verkehrsmontrolle, bei einer Schweißprobe plötzlich ein Phaetaminer entdeckt werden, die ich nie genommen habe, dann frag ich mich, wozu soll denn die ganze Technik sein?
Ja, ja, ja, das ist genau der Punkt. Ich denke, man sollte einfach mal drüber nachdenken, was man mit dieser ganzen Kohle vernünftiges machen kann. Und ich glaube, da ist Bildung, Aufklärung, Dialog, Konfliktbewältigung und so weiter in so einem, auch so ein bisschen, diese Schulung der Courage, letzten Endes gegen bestimmte Sachen auch vorzugehen, das sind Sachen, die ich für wesentlich halte, die auch tatsächlich Kriminalität nach unten bringen würde und das Vertrauen der Leute ineinander und vor allem in den Staat, und der Staat sind, eigentlich mal war das so gedacht, sind die Menschen, das wird erhöht. Und heute soll ich einem Staat vertrauen, der mir überhaupt nicht vertraut, das kommt mir dann schon komisch an.
Man muss ja aber auch der Gerechtigkeit halber sagen, dass schon in Deutschland die Situation im Vergleich zu anderen Industrieländern nicht unbedingt am schlimmsten ist, was so, wenn man die USA nimmt, oder auch, ich sag mal, was so das Misstrauen der Bürger, des Staates gegen seine Bürger angeht und repressive Maßnahmen und so weiter, denke ich, ist es in vielen Ländern unangenehmer. Und da gibt es mehr Anlass zur Sorge als bei uns.
Cool, ich fühl mich gleich viel besser.
Ich muss jetzt dazwischen reden, weil ihr habt uns wahrscheinlich auf dem Telefon. Und ihr habt Nummer eins, ihr fasst euch nicht kurz, sorry. Aber bei der Telekom, da muss man sich kurz.
Okay, reden wir dazwischen.
Nee, ich meine, die Sache ist die, um es mal so zu klären. Ich meine, jetzt haben wir den Verhältnis zwischen Personal aus was. Ich weiß, es gab die Diskussion, Polizeistaat und so weiter und so weiter. Also ich sag jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, ich fühle mich eigentlich in den all den Jahren genauso sicher oder unsicher wie vorher. Mit anderen Worten, ich fühle mich nicht unbedingt in Polizeistaat. Ich hab jetzt nicht das Gefühl, dass man mit der Kamera in mein Fenster reingucken kann. Und wenn sie es können, ich meine, das ist eine andere Geschichte. Es gibt ja auch Gerüchte, das wisst ihr auch, dass mehr oder weniger es irgendwo einen Zentralkomputer gibt, wo alle Daten, aber wirklich alle Daten, also jede Bewegung von dir gespeichert wird. Ob das stimmt oder nicht, weiß ich nicht. Ich hab Gerüchte, wo ich sagen würde, okay, den kann ich glauben. Ich hab zwar mehrere unterschiedliche Quellen gehört, weil die andere Sache ist, es gibt Spionagesatelliten. Und wofür die eingesetzt werden würden, möchte ich gar nicht wissen. Das ist eine Sache. Ich denke mir, diese ganze Sicherheitsgeschichte, wie ihr schon gesagt habt, eine Augenwischerei. Es geht einfach nur darum, uns zu beruhigen, zu sagen, aha, wir sind sicher, jetzt kommen keine Pillaristen mehr.
Es ist ja aber auch nicht ganz illegitim, also auch die Leute zu beruhigen, weil viele Leute machen sich natürlich auch erst mal überflüssige Sorgen. Die Medien tun ihr eigenes Ding dazu, die Leute ein bisschen hysterisch zu machen. Dann kann man den Politikern natürlich zugestehen, die Leute ein bisschen zu beruhigen.
Ich hab jetzt kein Fennich mehr Geld mehr drauf.
Wir sind auch gespannt, wie viel 40 Fennich wirklich sind dann noch, nicht in Länge.
Ach, null? Dann nun red schon.
Ja, also die Sache ist, die ich hab selber erlebt, weil ich eben bei der Auskunft arbeite, dass eben die Leute natürlich Angst hatten. Da kamen Dinger drin, wie jetzt bombardieren die Amis auf uns, weil die Terroristen bei uns waren und so weiter und so fort. Die Angst ist da und die Angst ist immer da. Und um sie dazu zu beruhigen, ist okay. Nur denke ich mir, die andere Geschichte ist, diese Angst, die ich oder nicht die Angst, die ich habe, ist, dass sie mir tatsächlich irgendwann mal Antifaltencreme oder Haarwuchsmittel oder Rasierschaum oder sowas schicken.
Das wird dein geringstes Problem sein, Sascha. Ich danke dir erst mal, wir wollen das jetzt wirklich nicht auskosten, dass du dann wegbrichst und immer schön...
Ich breche aus dem Schuh.
Ich denke, es gibt einen ganz wichtigen Punkt, auf den man noch eingehen muss und zwar, also bei den heiligsten Beteuerungen, dass ja alle diese Daten nur dazu verwendet werden, die bösen Terroristen zu jagen und dass damit ja kein Missbrauch passieren wird, gibt es immer das Problem, dass auch die politischen Verhältnisse sich mal ändern können, dass dann ein Berlusconi wie in Italien oder ein Schil wie in Hamburg oder wie hieß der gleich in Österreich, wenn einfach solche Leute an die Macht kommen, die der Meinung sind, es gibt da ein Gesetz, das erlaubt mir das, also tu ich das, also komme ich an diese Daten ran, da wird mir schon ein bisschen mulmig. Also es ist Potenzial dazu, im Zweifelsfall die Demokratie zu übernehmen, indem man auf demokratischem Wege, also per Wahl, an die Macht kommt und dann dafür sorgt, dass man die Macht nicht mehr abgeben muss. Bush probiert ja gerade sowas ähnliches in den USA, wo ein Gesetz namens Patriot Act verabschiedet wurde, dass sich die Abgeordneten noch nicht mal durchlesen konnten, bevor es verabschiedet wurde. Im Prinzip erst seit 200 Jahren keinen Präsidenten in den USA gehabt, der so viel Macht in sich vereint hat, der sich anmaßt, jetzt irgendwie selber Gericht zu halten, selber urteilen zu können über Terroristen und so weiter.
Man bedenke, dass der Bush nicht mal wirklich ausreichend legitimiert ist, mit gerade mal mit Ach und Krach 50 Prozent der Stimmen.
Ja, und jetzt haben sie...
Noch unklarer war es nie.
Ja, sie haben nachgezählt und hätte sogar verloren gehabt, wenn sie alle Stimmen normal nachgezählt haben.
Da habe ich was anderes gehört, das wird man sicherlich auch nie wirklich rausfinden.
Das ist aber auch gar nicht der Punkt.
Aber es ist in der Tat so. Aber ein Grund, ich denke, warum es sich nicht so gravierend verschlechtert hat, unsere persönliche Freiheit ist, dass es auch viele Leute gibt, die drauf aufpassen, die halt wirklich dafür kämpfen und sich dafür einsetzen, dass sich der Staat irgendwo zurückhält.
Ist es denn nicht so, dass es im Endeffekt dann doch wieder gut ist, dass zum Beispiel Schily sowas aufs Tapet bringt, weil es jeden Einzelnen einfach wieder dazu, naja, nicht nur armeetmutig, sondern einfach dazu bringt, nochmal darüber nachzudenken, dass es wichtig ist, dass sich jeder einfach selber darum kümmert und jeder auf der Straße daran drängt und ein bisschen mehr Sicherheit allein dadurch zustande kommt?
Ich habe mit Entsetzen gesehen, wie zwar eine Minderheit, so wie ich das wahrgenommen habe, aber das schon begeistert aufgenommen hat und einfach gesagt hat, ach wunderbar, ist doch gut, was soll schon dabei sein, dann machen wir halt, fühle ich mich besser. Und das verschiebt natürlich, wenn man so etwas Extremes ins Spiel bringt, dann verschiebt es die Mitte. Das ist das eigentliche Problem an dieser Diskussion.
Die da Pro waren, das sind wahrscheinlich die gleichen gewesen, die satanische Kulte hinter Harry Potter vermuten. Aber ihr könnt weiter anrufen, 031 77 97 1 1 0. Es geht um Biometrie, um Überwachung und alles was hinten dran hängt, werden zeitweilig ganz, ganz viele Anrufer, die natürlich, weil wir versprechen ab diesem Zeitpunkt auch, uns kurz zu heilen, nicht rangekommen sind. Wir sind unglaublich kurz ab jetzt. 0331 77 97 1 1 0 ist die Nummer am Telefon, ist der Thomas aus Potsdam, namens Thomas.
Hallo, schon guten Abend. Es gibt nicht nur satanische Kulte hinter Harry Potter, es gibt viel anderes, wesentlich größerem Volumen, denke ich mal.
Der Roman ist gar nicht verschlüsselt worden.
Nein, wenn er verschlüsselt gewesen wäre, wäre es noch wesentlich besser gewesen. Die ganzen Daten, die einfach gesammelt werden, wenn man schon einkaufen geht, man bezahlt mit der Euro, checkt sie in irgendeinem Laden. Man bestellt übers Internet irgendetwas bei irgendeinem deutschen großen Versandhaus und gleichzeitig wird man von dem Auto an die nächsten Straßenecke überfahren und die Krankenkasse schmeißt diese Daten mit diesen Einkaufsdaten alle komplett zusammen. Und dann im besten noch diese biometrischen Daten, die der Staat erfassen will. Das gibt ein wunderbares Profil. Der Staat hat kein Recht an irgendwelchen biometrischen Daten, meinerseits denke ich. Ich hinterlasse schon genügend Daten. Ich habe nur einen Reisepass und einen abgelaufenen Personalausweis. Das ist fünf Jahre abgelaufen.
Wow, das ist aber wohl. Du kannst dich nicht ausweisen.
Ja, ich kann mich ausweisen mit meinem Reisepass und meinem Führerschein.
Ja, Reisepass und Meldestätigung kommt mir auch wunderbar nicht klar.
Die Meldestätigung kann man...
Die muss man aber einmal wieder erneuern lassen.
Ja, aber die kriegt man irgendwie. Da kann man hingehen und dann kriegt man eine Meldestätigung. Ich finde es ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen sehr seltsam. Ein Fingerabdruck in einem Personalausweis, wenn der auf dem Personalausweis oben drauf ist, aber die Daten nicht gespeichert sind, ist wunderbar in Ordnung. Und Biometrie an sich finde ich total klasse. Es ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert. Ich finde es toll, die biometrischen Möglichkeiten und Biometrie für Zugangskontrollen. Und zwar wirklich für Einzelzugangskontrollen. Wenn ich in einer Firma arbeite, gucke ich da in eine nette Kamera rein und meine Iris aufnommen. Ich darf kein gehen, muss unter Umständen meine Pin oder sonst irgendetwas benutzen oder eine Karte reinschieben. Dafür ist es klasse. Oder um meine Haustüre aufzuschließen mit passender Technik oder meinen Fernseher zu bedienen. Aber das ist meine Sache, welche Daten ich preisgebe und wie ich es bediene.
Ja, das ist, denke ich, auf jeden Fall ein ganz wichtiges Merkmal. Freiwilligkeit für die Akzeptanz von jeder Technologie. Wobei da wieder die Gefahr ist, die man auch gesehen hat, jetzt im Zusammenhang mit den DNA-Analysen, mit den Großflächigen, die gemacht worden sind, im Zusammenhang mit einigen ziemlich abscheulichen Verbrechen. Da kam es halt dazu, dass zwar die Leute freiwillig, dann aufgefordert wurden, freiwillig etwas abzugeben, aber doch erheblichen Repressalien ausgesetzt waren, wenn sie dann nicht freiwillig sich bereit erklärt haben.
Ja natürlich, wenn diese Daten danach nicht weiter verwendet werden, finde ich es an sich in diesem Fall ein legitimes Mittel des Staates. Ungekehrt gesehen, welches Recht hat denn der Staat daran, von mir irgendwelche biometrischen Daten überhaupt zu erfassen?
Das Problem ist, ich traue, so wie ich den deutschen Staat kennengelernt habe, habe ich noch einiges Vertrauen, dazu jedenfalls mehr Vertrauen, als beispielsweise zum amerikanischen Staat, muss ich sagen. Das Problem ist nur, dass vermutlich alle Daten, die der deutsche Staat hat, auch dem amerikanischen Staat zur Verfügung stehen und wahrscheinlich sogar noch das eine oder andere mehr.
Also nein, ich denke, dass das an sich nicht das große Problem ist. Selbst wenn der amerikanische Staat alles über meine Person weiß und in meiner Wohnung selbst eine Wanne sitzen würde, ist das rein persönlich betrachtet nicht das Problem.
Das wird in dem Moment für dich aber nur ein Problem, wenn du zum Beispiel Geschäfte machst mit amerikanischen Firmen oder mit irgendwelchen anderen Firmen und die Amerikaner sich überlegen oder eine amerikanische Firma sich sagt, das ist nicht in unserem Interesse, dass du das machst und dann halt entsprechende Möglichkeiten hast, dafür zu sorgen, dass dein Geschäft beispielsweise so nicht zustande kommt, wie das in mehreren Fällen geschehen ist. Und insofern wird das dann sehr leicht ganz schnell einfach zu deinem Problem.
Also gar nicht davon zu reden, dass man über zum Beispiel Spracherkennung bei Mitschneiden von Telefonaten gar nicht wissen muss, wer mit wem, sondern es ist einfach von der Spracherkennung her schon möglicherweise ausreichend zu sagen, aha, das ist die Person, die hier spricht, egal ob das eine geheime Nummer ist, egal ob das von der Telefonzelle aus ist und so weiter.
Nein, das spielt an sich keine Rolle mehr. Das ist technisch wunderbar möglich.
Hast du eigentlich eine Bahncard?
Ich habe keine Bahncard. Ich weiß, was ich mit meiner Bahncard eintue.
Erzähl.
Diese Daten, die an Drittfirmen weitergeleitet werden, möchte ich nicht weitergeben.
Beispielsweise. Ja, dass dein Bild dann einfach in einem amerikanischen Computer landet, plus sämtliche persönlichen Daten, die noch damit zusammenhängen. Und es wird zwar versprochen, dass die halt dem Deutschen Datenschutzgesetz entsprechen, aber in Wirklichkeit kümmern die sich eigentlich ein Dreck drum, was da tatsächlich mit den Daten am Ende passiert.
Da werden Schienen gelegt, die weit über das deutsche Gebiet hinausführen.
Ich möchte nicht wissen, was passiert, wenn ich mit einer Eurocheckkarte in einem Supermarkt bezahle, sei es per Lastschrift oder per PIN, welche Daten trotz deutschem Datenschutzgesetz dann wirklich genutzt werden. Sie werden wahrscheinlich nur gesammelt.
Also wir hatten zum Beispiel, man fragt, man denkt sich...
Ist doch klar zu wissen, dass man gerne Schokolade und frische Milch einkauft und gerne teure, sagen wir so, höherpreisige Lebensmittel.
Danke erstmal Thomas, für all das. Die Frage soll jetzt mal im Raum stehen bleiben, was man damit anstellen kann. Danke dir, machs gut. Weil wir jetzt den Tom am Telefon haben, aus Neukölln, der ist nämlich beim LKA angestellt und kann was über die Möglichkeiten der Polizei erzählen. Deswegen würde ich gerne wissen, was die denn damit anfangen könnten, wenn sie überhaupt da ein Zugang haben. Tom, bist du noch dran?
Ich wusste es.
Oh nein.
Tom, bitte tu mir den Gefallen. Ruf nochmal an, ganz auf die Schnelle. Es würde mich sehr, sehr freuen für den Fall, dass dein Akku nicht alle ist, weil das würde uns schon interessieren, ob ihr vielleicht Zugriff auf diese Daten habt, ob ihr wisst, was für eine Art von Mozzarella ich kaufe. Das würde mich sehr, sehr, sehr interessieren.
Ich glaube nicht, dass er das tut. Aber da fällt mir noch die Sache ein, die ich auch erst vor kurzem erfahren habe, mit den Schufa-Ansagen.
Ach, die Schufa-Nummer, genau.
Und zwar hatte gut der Datenschutzbeauftragte, hat es erfolgreich dieser Praxis, hoffe ich, ein Ende gesetzt. Aber es war bis Mitte diesen Jahres zumindest so. Es gibt ja dieses Recht auf Selbstauskunft, wer welche Daten über mich gespeichert hat. Und die Schufa hat aber jetzt freundlicherweise, wenn man ihr Gegenüber von dem Recht auf Selbstauskunft Gebrauch gemacht hat und angefragt hat, was habt ihr denn für Daten über mich gespeichert, führte das dazu, dass sich das interne Rating, was man hat, automatisch durch jede Anfrage verschlechterte. Weil sich statistisch davon ausging, wer bei uns nachfragt, was über ihn gespeichert ist, der ist halt irgendwie weniger kreditwürdig. Und das heißt, so drei Selbstanfragen oder vier bei der Schufa führten dann potentiell dazu, dass man nicht mehr kreditwürdig war. Ja, das ist ein Schach nur, weil solche Korken passieren halt auch immer noch.
Aber tätst du doch genau so? Wenn du schon anfragst, dann muss da ja was sein.
Das ist schon eine harte Nummer gewesen.
Der vergessliche Mensch meldet sich da viermal, kommt zur Bank und die Frau macht nur, sie ist ein Terrorist. Ist natürlich sehr ungünstig.
Nein, die sagen mir ganz freundlich, leider können wir ihrem Kreditantrag nicht stattgeben.
Aber das hat nun irgendwie gar nichts mit Biometrie zu tun.
Nein, aber mit der Art und Weise, wie man darauf vertrauen kann, dass sensibel mit den Dingen umgegangen ist.
Ich glaube, es ist eigentlich mit allem so, oder wie das auch mit anderen Substanzen ist, die Menge Macht, dass es Gift ist. Genau, es ist hier auch der Umgang Macht, dass es Gift ist letzten Endes, das heißt, dass es schädlich ist. Wenn alle vertrauensvoll damit umgehen würden, dann wäre das Grundgesetz super cool. Dann wäre das eine vernünftige Einrichtung. Das deutsche Grundrecht, das klingt ja nicht schlecht, so wie es geschrieben steht. Es ist nur immer eine Vertrauens- und Auslegungssache. Wenn alles gut wäre, dann gibt es auch keine Kriminellen. Aber das ist halt nicht so.
Mal gucken, ob der Kevin noch am Telefon ist. Kevin, bist du noch da? Wunderschönen guten Abend. Was ist deine Frage für das heutige Thema?
Ich möchte erst mal kurz widersprechen zum Thema Schufa. Weil ich aus der Branche komme, da wird nicht aufgeachtet, wie viele Anfragen drin sind, sondern wirklich was für Fakten drin stehen.
Das musst du jetzt sagen, stimmt's? Das muss ich jetzt sagen.
Die Quelle, aus der ich das habe, ist das Büro des Datenschutzbeauftragten. Und ich glaube nicht, dass der sich das ausgedacht hat, dass es so war, dass selbstauskünftig...
Die Kreditentscheidungen davon leider nicht abhängen. Die hängen wirklich davon ab, was steht drin. Nicht wie viele Anfragen sind dran, sondern...
Gibt es denn bei der Schufa so eine Bewertung pro Person, die sagt, der ist vom Prinzip her so und so kreditwürdig? Welche Daten stehen denn jetzt wirklich drin in so einem Schufa? Jetzt haben wir doch mal jemanden vom Fach da. Du kannst uns doch mal erklären, wie ist es denn? Scheift ein bisschen ab, aber interessiert mich jetzt doch.
Ja, das steht drin, wie viele Girokonten da sind, wie viele Kreditkarten da sind.
Auch wie oft die benutzt werden?
Nein, nein, definitiv nicht. Wie viele Kredite da sind, wie lange die laufen, nicht bei welchen Instituten.
Steht denn drin, wie viel auf deinem Konto drauf ist und wie die Bewegungen da so sind?
Gut haben, Gelder stehen gar nicht drin. Und was sonst noch drin steht, Haftbefehle und sonstige.
Aber wenn ich mal zum Beispiel einen Kredit nicht zurückgezahlt habe, ich hätte Schwierigkeiten oder habe ein Jahr gebraucht, so was steht drin, ne?
In welcher Form steht das drin? Ist das so ein Rating? Gibt es dieses Rating? Gibt es irgendwie?
Nein, Rating direkt nicht. Also es ist so, dass ich sehe, was drin steht. Konnte in Abwicklung, Kredit nicht zurückgezahlt oder sonstige Sachen, wie viele Gero-Konten und so weiter, wie gesagt. Und dann muss ich mir eben ein Bild machen, bist du kreditwürdig oder eben nicht.
Verjährt sowas, wenn ich mal Scheiße gebaut habe?
Nein, wenn es irgendwann nicht ist, ja.
Ja, gut, aber ich meine, nehme mal, ich habe zwei Jahre dafür gebraucht, das alles ins Reine zu bringen, bin dann wieder braver Bundesbürger. Wie lange würde sowas drin stehen?
Das kann ich jetzt nicht genauer sagen.
Das macht der Computer halt, ne?
Nach Gusto! Da würde ich auch keine falschen Auskünfte geben.
Was hältst du denn von der ganzen Fingerabdruck-Diskussion oder der ganzen Biometriediskussion, die aufgekommen ist nach den Anschlägen?
Na, also im Grunde wenig. Weil Terrorismus ist da, ob der Fingerabdruck da ist oder nicht. Aber meine Frage ist eher dahingehend, inwieweit Biometrie eingesetzt werden kann. Und zwar gibt es Systeme, die die Schrift vergleichen. Und dazu habe ich eben die Frage, ob das nicht sinnvoll ist. Weil es gibt ja doch, wenn ich eine Unterschrift leiste, gewisse Punkte, die bei meiner Unterschrift immer gleich sind. Und da ist eben die Frage, ob das fälschungssicher ist. Weil wenn ich meine Kakelein mache, das kann eben in der Regel keiner so schnell machen wie ich. Und gut, ob der Mensch das jetzt vom Auge her vergleichen kann, ist die eine Sache. Aber der PC oder Programme dürfen ja doch von einem anderen Punkt finden.
Es gibt auch da zum einen die prinzipiellen Schwierigkeiten von biometrischen Verfahren, dass sich auch deine Schrift ändert. Es gibt des Weiteren das Problem, dass natürlich die Unterschrift nicht zur Identitätsprüfung insofern geeignet ist, als dass du bei der Abgabe des Musters bzw. zur Authentifizierung die Unterschrift bewusst manipulieren kannst. Das heißt, du kannst unterschiedliche Arten von Unterschriften zunächst mal leisten. Aber das Hauptproblem ist, dass wenn du deinen Unterschriftenmuster leistest, damit derjenige, der dein Unterschriftenmuster aufnimmt, in der Lage ist, deine Unterschrift auch ziemlich gut zu fälschen. Das heißt, du gibst sie doch, du gibst die Preise. In dem Moment, wo du auf so einem Digitalisierbrett jetzt unterschreibst, ist es einfach möglich, hast du genau die Schreibdynamik und es ist möglich, dann einen Automaten anzufertigen, der genau diese Unterschrift dann sogar mechanisch produziert.
Also das Wichtigste bei der Grafologie...
Wenn ich jetzt irgendwo eine Kontrolle mache, dann habe ich ja nicht direkt ein PC vor mir stehen, der meine Unterschrift nachmacht, sondern dann muss ja der Mensch, der mir gegenüber steht, in der Lage sein, meine Unterschrift nachzumachen.
Gut, wenn jemand davor steht und ihm dabei zugesehen wird, wie er die Unterschrift leistet, sicher. Aber in dem Moment, wo du halt ein Dokument einfach unterschreibst oder einen Überweisungsauftrag einwirfst oder eine Steuererklärung unterzeichnest oder einen Vertrag unterzeichnest, muss nicht notwendigerweise jemand daneben stehen. Wie gesagt, es ist sicherlich, also die Schrifterkennung ist auf jeden Fall ein praktikables und praktiziertes Verfahren für bestimmte Anwendungen, aber eben, wie gesagt, gerade die digitale Unterschrift abzunehmen, ist unsicherer gegen Nachmachen als eine Unterschrift zu fälschen, die auf einem Papierformwurf vorliegt.
Ich will da noch mal auf einen anderen Aspekt, wenn du so eine Unterschrift nachmachen willst. Und du hast schon recht, wenn einer daneben steht und guckt, wie ich unterschreibe, dann muss ich das geübt haben. Das Problem, weshalb das heute schwer fälschbar ist, ist einfach, dass beim Üben ich ein schlechtes oder gar kein Feedback habe, ob ich das richtig gemacht habe. Weil bei der Unterschrift ja nicht die Optik geprüft wird, sondern die Schreibdynamik und die Andruckstärke, die Dynamik der Andruckstärke. Das ist das, was heute geprüft wird. Wie das Bild aussieht, ist am Ende völlig wurscht. Sondern die Frage, wo fange ich an, wie mache ich den Bogen, wie schnell bin ich in der Kurve, wie doll habe ich gedrückt dabei. Meine Unterschrift sieht jedes Mal anders aus und trotzdem würde so eine Authentifizierung darüber funktionieren. Weil klar ist, wie meine Dynamik funktioniert. Aber, wenn ich als Mensch, der das üben will, ich habe, wenn ich übe, nur das optische Malmerkmal. Ich kann jetzt nur optisch diesen Schriftzug nachmachen. Anderes Feedback habe ich ja nicht und ich kann dann vergleichen, hat es gestimmt. Wenn ich jetzt aber ein Grafiktablett habe, das tatsächlich Schreibdynamik und Andruckstärke aufnimmt und wiedergeben kann, dann kann ich solange üben, weil ich das Feedback habe, bis ich diese Unterschrift beherrsche. Das mag ein wenig komplizierter sein, als eine normale Unterschrift nachzumachen. Aber ich garantiere, in allerhöchstens zwei Wochen kannst du auch, wenn du ein Feedback hast für die Charakteristik, diese Unterschrift eines Menschen nachmachen lernen. Und ich muss mal sagen, wenn ich besoffen bin, unterschreibe ich echt anders, aber richtig ganz anders.
Das Problem ist, wenn man diese Mühe auf sich nimmt, auch die Schriftdynamik und den Andruck usw. zu trainieren, hat man hinterher eine Unterschrift, auch wenn man analog unterschreibt, die dann ein Grafologe nicht mehr von der echten Unterschrift unterscheiden kann. Gegensatz zu einer Unterschrift, wo jemand bloß nachmalt, was man halt relativ oft sieht.
Das heißt, es ist im Umkehrschluss fatal, wenn es Systeme gibt, mit denen du deine Unterschrift abgibst auf einem solchen Grafiktablett. Wenn du auf so einem Grafiktablett unterschreibst, hast du das einzige unveränderliche Merkmal preisgegeben und das ich brauche, um zu üben, die Unterschrift nachzumachen, sodass sie auch einem normalen Grafologen entspricht. Und dann hast du ein Geheimnispreis gegeben, das mich dazu befähigt, deine Unterschrift perfekt zu fälschen. Deswegen ist es fatal, solche Systeme einzufälschen.
Kurze Frage aber, immer wieder die Frage, die man sich stellt. Who the fuck cares, weil wie wichtig sind wir, dass jemand sich wirklich zwei Wochen hinsetzt, um gerade meine Unterschrift zu fälschen? Bausparverträge, Kontoeröffnungen auf deinen Namen.
Da geht es um echtes Geld, da geht es um 100.000 Mark. Und für 100.000 Mark setzt man sich immer zwei Wochen?
Gerade beim Normalbürger, der sonst an der Stelle nichts zu befürchten hätte, wenn man so mit dem normalen Menschenverstand herangeht.
Ich kann in deinem Namen, wenn ich einen Personalausweis noch machen kann, und die kann man heute kaufen, haben wir gerade gehört, in Kolumbien ist das billig, dann ich besorge einen Personalausweis, ich mache deine Unterschrift so nach, dass der Grafologe sie nicht mehr unterscheiden kann, sobald ich diese Merkmale kenne. Und du hast ein echtes Problem, du verlierst deine Identität, ich nehme sie an und ich bringe dich in Grund und Boden, das reicht dabei und du kommst da nie wieder raus.
Aber das mit dem Baustoffvertrag, das machen wir, weil ich kriege nämlich wieder gerade keinen. Wir machen erst mal Nachrichten, ich danke dem Kevin. Kevin, danke dir. Tschüss, mach's gut.
Wenn Fritz in Berliner Kabel, dann 89, 85.
0, 31.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Mit dem Wetter nachts wolkig und trocken 4 bis 1 Grad, tachsverbreitet Regen 4 bis 7 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Gerald Kötter-Heinrich.
Ägypten hat die USA vor einem Angriff auf Irak gewarnt. Damit würden die USA die Unterstützung der arabischen Staaten im Kampf gegen den Terrorismus verlieren, sagte Außenminister Maher in Washington. Gegen eine Ausweitung der militärischen Einsätze sprachen sich gestern auch Bundeskanzler Schröder und Außenminister Fischer aus. Der US-Geheimdienst CIA hat den Tod eines seiner Mitarbeiter in Afghanistan bestätigt. Der Agent sei während einer Gefangenenrevolte nahe der Stadt Masar-e-Sharif ums Leben gekommen. Bei dem Aufstand wurden hunderte Taliban-Kämpfer getötet. Die Berliner Grünen haben ein prominentes Gründungsmitglied verloren. Wie die Berliner Zeitung berichtet, trat Elmer Altvater Professor an der Freien Universität aus Protest gegen den Afghanistan-Krieg aus der Partei aus. In Berlin haben sich SPD, Grüne und FDP bei ihren Koalitionsgesprächen auf Einsparungen in den Bereichen Schule und Sport geeinigt. In der Frage der Olympiabewerbung für 2012 waren sie sich noch uneins. Zum Fußball der 1. FC Union Berlin hat die nächste Runde des DFB Pokals erreicht. Der Zweitligist siegte beim Verbandsligisten SSV Ulm mit 3 zu 0. Nächste Runde Union übrigens gegen Oberhausen und Hertha bei Eintracht Frankfurt. Und jetzt noch das Champions League Spiel zwischen Juventus Turin und Bayer Leverkusen zum zweiten Mal abgesagt. Morgen 15 Uhr neuer Termin.
Schöne Tradition.
In Juventus ist das so. A12 Richtung Frankfurt oder an der Grenze zu Polen. Circa 2 Stunden Wartezeit für PKW. Und das ist an der Grenze zu Polen auch so.
Jeden Samstagabend ab 22 Uhr auf Fritz. Die Sendung zur Party-Nacht mit DJs, Club-News, Party-Tipps, den Glorious Sisters und mit Anja Schneider.
033, knapp eine halbe Stunde noch im Chaosradio. Blue moon im Studio, sind der Pavel, Andreas 1 und Andreas 2, auch Steine genannt und Hosten tut das ganze Max von Malotki. Wunderschönen guten Abend nochmal. Telefonnummer ist die 033 177 97 110. Wir warten noch sehnlichst zum Beispiel auf den Tom vom Landeskriminalamt, der uns einiges über Methoden erzählen wollte. Er hat nämlich bis jetzt noch nicht angerufen. Ich würde mich sehr freuen Tom, wir werden dich auch nicht zu Sau machen. Und du weißt, wir stellen nur kurze Fragen und geben kurze Antworten. 033 177 97 110 ist die Nummer. Und der Hansi ist am Telefon. Nachmittag Hansi. Was ist dir widerfahren?
Was ist mir widerfahren? Ich habe ein ganz interessantes Erlebnis gehabt. Und seitdem so ein bisschen das Vertrauen in den Staat verloren. Und zwar, ich komme ursprünglich aus Hamburg.
Da wo die Terroristen herkommen.
Die angeblichen Terroristen sagen wir mal so. Und da hatte ich eines Tages das Erlebnis, ich wollte morgens zur Arbeit. Und stand ein Polizeibahn vor der Tür. Die fragten mich dann auch ganz nett, wo denn hier diese Hausnummer sei. Ich so, ja das ist hier, bla bla. Und dann sah ich nur, wie die in das Haus reingingen, in dem ich wohne. Hab mir nichts dabei gedacht und so, komme abends wieder, bla bla, schlafe. Nächsten Morgen um 5 Uhr auf einmal ein Riesenlärm. Es bummert an die Tür, es bummert gleichzeitig am Fenster. Ein Geschrei, noch und nöcher. Ich sehe nur, bei den Nachbarhäusern geht schon das Licht an. Das ist so mehrfamilienhäuser, muss man sich das vorstellen.
Welches Stockwerk?
Erdgeschoss.
Sonst hätte ich jetzt gestaunt.
Dritter Stock, die springen gut.
Was heißt es bummerte? Es war schon fast ein Tür eintreten und ich hab gedacht, was weiß ich, ein Gläubiger, ein Kumpel, und so.
Nicht geklingelt, gar nicht versucht, die Klingel zu benutzen?
Man muss dazu sagen, dass ich nachts meine Klingel abstelle. Ich stelle mein Handy ab, ich stelle meine Klingel ab, weil wenn ich meine Ruhe haben will, will ich meine Ruhe haben. Das war gelaufen. Dann ging es auf einmal mit Polizei aufmachen. Da dachte ich, was nun? Man muss sich auch sagen, ich bin nur nicht der Braveste, aber ich bin auch kein Verbrecher oder sonstiges. Die üblichen Jugend-Sachen machen nur auf und hält mir erstmal einen roten Schein dagegen, sagt schön guten Tag, packen Sie ein paar Sachen zusammen, siehe ihn fest, genau. Du musst dir vorstellen, du kommst gerade mitten aus dem Schlaf, stehen da so ein paar Leute vor dir und du bist fest. Du denkst, das ist ein blöder Film. Ich sag, können Sie nicht mal so später wiederkommen? Dann sagt er mir auch noch so, ich glaube nicht, Sie wissen nicht, worum es hier geht.
Dann hast du gesagt, stimmt.
Ja, richtig. Das erzählen wir ihm unterwegs.
Ich sag, alles klar. Ich hab ein paar Sachen mitgenommen, musste zusagen. Es war kurz nach dem ersten, ich hatte auch mal ein bisschen Geld. Also ein bisschen was eingesteckt.
Kurz nach dem ersten Mai, lass mich raten.
Es war direkt am ersten Mai. Aber wie gesagt, in Hamburg, also nicht in Berlin.
Ja, das soll vorgekommen sein.
Ich muss aber dazu sagen, ich hab mit dem ersten Mai insofern kaum was zu tun gehabt, außer dass ich da mal einmal als Pressereporter war. Also nicht das, was du denkst. So, und jetzt stellte sich dann nach und nach raus, ich kam erst mal auf eine Polizeiwache. Man hat mir bis dahin immer noch nicht gesagt, warum es ging. Es war auch nichts mit Telefonieren und sonst was, es war auch viel zu früh. Ich wusste gar nicht, wen sollte ich jetzt mal anrufen. So dieses berühmte Mein-Anwalt, ich hab keinen Anwalt, brauchte ich bisher nicht. Und ja, und dann hieß es nur, wir werden jetzt überführt. Und dann kam irgendwann so ein Knasttransporter, der tierisch nach Alkohol stank. Und da bin ich dann mit drei irgendwelchen winzernen Gesellen nach Hamburg Mitte gefahren worden, an der Altsalace. Das ist so ein großes U-Haft-Gefängnis. So, und da hab ich dann erst mal sieben Stunden in so einer komischen gekachelten Sammelzelle verbracht. Mit den wildesten Leuten. Der eine, der überführt wurde, weil er gerade seine Frau abgestochen hat, der und dies und das. Und man muss dazu sagen, es war ein Samstag. Und dann hieß es ja Haftrichter, das sieht wohl heute schlecht aus. Wohl am Montag erst wieder. Ich sag, na klasse, so. Dann hat man mir dann wenigstens irgendwann mal erzählt, worum es ging. Und jetzt war tatsächlich der Grund der Verhaftung, dass ich mehrfach als wichtiger Zeuge nicht zu einer Gerichtsverhandlung erschienen bin und dann vorgeführt werden sollte. Das Interessante an der ganzen Geschichte ist, ich war zu dem Zeitpunkt schon zwei Jahre in Hamburg an dieser Adresse gemeldet. Ich hab vorher ein Jahr in Berlin gewohnt, war in Berlin gemeldet, dann wieder in Hamburg, jetzt wieder Berlin. Und ich war aber ganz normal in Hamburg gemeldet mit Ausweis, mit allem drum und dran. Und das Gericht hätte diese Vorladung mehrfach an meine Berliner Adresse geschickt, die also schon zwei Jahre lang nicht mehr existierte. Und ja, dann hieß es, ich hätte mich nicht gemeldet. Meine Stimme wäre wichtig gewesen eben bei der Verhandlung. Und dadurch sollte ich eben vorgeführt werden. Und dann hätte man auch angemahnt irgendwie, ich wäre nicht erschienen und deshalb würde man mich jetzt vorführen. Und da es ein Wochenende ist und es wäre kein Haftrichter da, der es nicht entscheiden kann, es wäre kein Hamburger Richter, der es entschieden hat.
Aber Sekunde mal, es ist nicht normalerweise so, dass man dann von der Polizei abgeholt wird und dann setzt sich normalerweise erstmal ein Wachtmeister hin, der dann die Aussage aufnimmt. Das muss doch kein Haftrichter tun.
Nein, nein.
Also ich dachte, das wäre nicht nötig.
Es war wirklich so, die Polizisten haben nur gesagt, blablabla, haben wir nichts mit zu tun. Es ist dann so ausgegangen, dass zum Glück eine Haftrichterin noch aufzutreiben war, die sich dann auch wirklich bemüht hat, weil sie gesehen hat, ich war ganz normal, ich hab nix angestellt, ich hatte eine geregelte Arbeit. Die hat sich dann wirklich bemüht. Das Problem war nun, der ausstellende Richter dieses Haftbefehls, der saß irgendwo auf dem Land. Das war irgendein Landgericht. Und die sind nicht mehr zu erreichen am Samstag Nachmittag. Und die war nur ein bisschen schlau, die Haftrichterin, weil ich auch Rabatz gemacht hatte. Und die hat dann irgendwie über den Dorf-Sheriff und was weiß ich nicht alles, also irgendwie hat sie den Richter rangekriegt und hat gesagt, pass auf, der ist hier gemeldet seit zwei Jahren, bla bla bla. So nun war es dann so, dass ich dann gegen Samstag abends, so gegen 22 Uhr, haben sie mich dann wieder rausgelassen.
War deine Aussage in dem Fall denn wichtig?
Es ging um eine Drogengeschichte, ja.
Also wäre wirklich auch relevant gewesen und war jetzt nicht die reine Schikane?
Sie war insofern relevant, aber ich hab sie hinterher eh verweigert. Weil das Problem, es ging um einen Freund von mir, der vor ein paar Drogengeschichten verwickelt war.
Und du hättest dich selbst belastet?
Nee, ich hätte mich nicht unbedingt selbst belastet. Aber das Problem war, ich hätte ihn selber belastet. Weil er war so jemand, der sich mir halt immer anvertraut hatte. Und ich wusste nur halt alles über ihn. Ich hab sein halbes Leben begleitet. Und ich hab halt gesagt, mach dein Ding. Ich bin dein Freund so ungefähr, aber ich hab da nichts mit zu tun. Und nun hieß es halt nur irgendwie der und der ist mal sein Freund, der weiß alles. Und irgendeiner hatte halt erzählt, dass ich da wohl sehr viel drüber sagen könnte. Hätte ich auch machen können. Aber wie gesagt, das war für mich nicht relevant, weil es war eine Drogengeschichte und es war kein Mord und kein Raub. Und Drogen ist wie gesagt für mich, ja, weiß ich nicht, ist eine Ansichtssache, aber in meinen Augen kein Strafding. Und zumindest das, was da bei ihm jetzt irgendwie anlag. Nee, aber dieses Allgemeine, das hat mich so dermaßen schockiert. Du musst dir diese Situation vorstellen.
Du wirst aufs Bett geholt.
Und du erst mal dieses Klarwerden, es ist kein Traum, das ist jetzt hier Realität, das ist kein Film, das ist gar nichts. Und du weißt nicht warum. Du hast, wie gesagt, ich habe seit 16, 17 Jahren wirklich viel Mist gebaut. Und öfter auch mal so beim örtlichen Jugendrichter gelandet und durfte auch meinen Schulhof fegen und so eine Geschichten. Und da bist du wirklich brav und alles.
Welche Chancen, ich weiß nicht, weil ich da auch nicht Bescheid weiß, es würde mich immer interessieren, wenn da wirklich einer an meiner Tür klingelt, welche Chancen habe ich denn da zu entkommen, zu sagen, ich will zu Hause bleiben, ich möchte erst mal wissen worum es geht. Ist sowas überhaupt drin?
Also er hat mir gesagt, in dem Moment, wo er einen roten Schein in der Hand hält, also einen Haftbefehl, ist es ihm scheißegal. Es ist ihm wirklich scheißegal. Er hat einen Haftbefehl, der gilt, und das hat der Haftrichter zu entscheiden und keine Ahnung.
Wenn du Pech hast, weiß der nicht mal, warum er dich abholt. Richtig. Das ist ein 47 Bericht durch 11 und der wird halt gemacht.
Und es ist tatsächlich am besten, wirklich so schnell wie möglich einen Anwalt hinzuzuziehen.
Ja, aber versuch mal zu telefonieren. Ich hab dann auch gesagt, wie sieht denn das aus? Ich denke, ich kenn's jetzt nur aus Filmen, man darf irgendwie telefonieren. Ja, ja, später. Also ich hätte in der Zeit gar nicht telefonieren können. Und dann kommen noch so Sachen dazu, wie Gürtel abgeben, Uhr abgeben, also das. Ich sag, Entschuldigung, ich bin der Letzte, der mich jetzt hier umbringen will, ich weiß noch nicht mehr, warum ich hier bin. Ja, ist egal, ich hab meine Vorschrift.
Das Lustige ist vor allen Dingen das nächste Mal, wenn du in eine Polizeikontrolle kommst und wenn sie dich angucken nach dem Motto, wir haben sie doch letztens erst auf dem Revier gehabt. Und ob das aus sich aufgequert hat oder nicht. Sie haben wir doch schon mal gehabt, nicht?
Wie siehst und wie hast du jetzt das mit der Biometrie dann verfolgt oder wahrgenommen aufgefasst, nachdem nun dein Vertrauen in den Staat schon etwas erschüttert war?
Das ist jetzt eigentlich genau das Gegenteil. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe da eigentlich nicht so die Bedenken vor. Nicht jetzt, dass es passieren wird oder geplant ist, sondern ich habe seitdem, seit dieser Aktion, wie gesagt, so ein bisschen das Vertrauen verloren. Und das lag zum Beispiel daran, ich habe ein Jahr später ist mein Personalausweis abgelaufen und ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe bis heute keinen neuen beantragt. Und ich habe auch keinen Reisepass. Also nicht wie der Kollege vorhin, das heißt, ich habe zur Zeit, wenn man so will, keine gültigen Papiere. Und das sind einfach so Kleinigkeiten. Es ist einfach so wie das Ding... Ja, erstmal das Unbehagen ist vielleicht wieder doch irgendwas, wenn ich jetzt irgendwas beantrage und so. Und dann kam so das zweite, ich wollte es einfach mal probieren, weil mir jeder gesagt hat, es geht nicht. Du kannst in Deutschland nicht ohne Papiere leben, das geht nicht. Und es geht wunderbar. Ich habe eine Wohnung gekriegt ohne Papiere, ich habe sogar ein Konto gekriegt ohne Papiere. Es geht, man muss halt unbedingt auftreten, man muss einen seriösen Eindruck machen, man muss ein bisschen was zeigen können und man muss reden können.
Machen sie mal einen Handstandüberschlag. Aber ganz im Ernst, hast du dann deinen abgelaufenen Ausweis vorgezeigt und die haben ihn nicht erkannt als abgelaufen oder hast du gar nichts vorgezeigt?
Nein, ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe einen uralten Kinderausweis, also der ist jetzt 11 Jahre abgelaufen und da sehe ich auch ziemlich putzig drauf aus. Und ich habe dann immer so diese Jammergeschichte, von wegen gerade beklaut worden gestern, U-Bahn, bla bla, Portemonnaie mit allem drum und dran und sie können sich gar nicht vorstellen, wie das ist, Papiere zu beantragen und keine Zeit und Arbeitgeber lässt das eigentlich raus und bla bla. Aber ich habe in der Schublade auch einen alten Kinderausweis gefunden. Dann zeigt man den vor und die Leute sagen, oh wie niedlich das Foto. Ja, ich habe wirklich festgestellt, es ist einfach eine Frage des Auftretens. Also wie bringe ich das rüber und so. Und momentan, ich muss sagen, ich habe zur Zeit, ich brauche momentan kein Personal. Ich habe eigentlich alles, wofür man einen bräuchte. Das einzige, was vielleicht interessant wäre, wenn ich jetzt mal verreisen will. Aber da steht die nächste Zeit sowieso nicht an. Aber es ist einfach wirklich mal so ein Ding gewesen, wo ich jetzt gesagt habe, so jetzt probiere ich es mal. Und ja.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine interessante Sache, dass es so geht.
Es geht wunderbar. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es wäre, wenn man jetzt, ich sage mal so, ich will es kein schlecht machen, aber ich bin jetzt der Alkoholiker oder Plattenbauer, dreckigst dagegen. Ob das bei dem vielleicht genauso klappen würde, das weiß ich nicht.
Also ich weiß nicht. Ich brauche das Ding dauernd, ehrlich. Das will ständig jemand sehen. Da gehst du auf die Post, willst ein Päckchen abholen, wollen sie das Ding sehen, dann wirst du ein Konto öffnen, wollen sie das Ding sehen, ich brauche das Ding echt dauernd.
Größere Geldbeträge.
Wie oft öffnest du ein Konto? Ich hab mein Konto jetzt seit 10 Jahren, ich hab immer noch das Gleiche.
Aber Päckchen abholen von der Post, das mache ich schon dauernd.
Päckchen kannst du auch ohne Ausweis abholen. Du kannst doch keine einschreiben, ohne Ausweis.
Nein, ein Paket kannst du nicht abholen. Ich konnte nicht mal meinen TDSL-Hiny abholen, ohne meinen Perso.
Na siehste, dann musst du dir das schicken lassen, ist alles kein Thema.
Ich hab mir ja schicken lassen, die erste Scheißpostbote hat sie an die hochgetragen. Das macht er immer.
Beispiel einschreiben. Einschreiben ist ein gutes Beispiel. Ein Einschreiben kriegst du absolut nicht ohne Ausweis. Aber geh mal zur Post und sag, du möchtest ein Paket abholen, du kriegst es ohne Ausweis. Die sagen dir jetzt mittlerweile schon, sie brauchen dich nicht. Also im Prenzlberg, Prenzlo Allee, da sagen sie dir im Postamt, von wegen brauchen sie dich nicht, nur wenn ich mir in die Tasche schon greife.
Also bei mir haben sie einen riesen Affentanz gemacht.
Das ist ungerecht.
Du wohnst ja auch in Mitte.
Außerdem hast du einen sehr schönen Kinderhaus. Machs gut erst mal, wir haben noch ein paar Leute am Telefon.
Halt, vorher, bevor es vergessen geht und Tim uns haut und schlägt, wir müssen unbedingt mal auf eine ganz großartige Sache hinweisen. Und da muss jetzt der Wert der nächste Anrufe auch mal warten. Wir müssen nämlich hinweisen auf eine Installation, die sich nennt Blinkenlights. Das haben wir versprochen, dass wir das bloß nicht vergessen. Und was ein Glück ist, uns das jetzt noch wieder eingefallen. Ja, was ist das denn? Blinkenlights. Das ist einfach der Hammer. Das ist echt cool. Und zwar ist es eine Installation aus 144 Lampen. Die haben Alexanderplatz im Haus des Lehrers.
Hast du noch nicht gesehen?
Natürlich, ich bin einer der langsamen Fahrer, die immer mit 30 über die Kreuzung fahren und denken, entweder steuert da jetzt wirklich einer mit seinem Handy und was sieht man gerade unter das Herz und so.
Also, Haus des Lehrers am Alexanderplatz, gleich neben der Kongresshalle, da sind hinter jedem Fenster 8x18 so ein Baustrahler, 100 Watt installiert, da ist ein Computer dahinter. Mit massig Relais, das ist eine absolut abgefahrene Konstruktion, macht Klicker, die klickt die ganze Zeit. Da laufen Filme bzw. kleine Sequenzen ab. Das ist ein Mini-Display, kann man sich vorstellen. Der ist so groß, wie ein Hochhaus nochmal groß ist. Das heißt, momentan eins der größten Displays in der Stadt und wahrscheinlich überhaupt, hat die so eine hohe Auflösung. Aber das Schöne daran ist, man kann da richtig selbst Spaß mit haben. Man kann eine 0190-Nummer anrufen, die einem erlaubt, dann Pong damit zu spielen, alleine oder zu zweit.
Vom Handy aus?
Vom Handy aus auf dem Alexanderplatz stehen und Pong auf dem Hochhaus spielen. Das ist echt Kult. Weiß jemand die Nummer auswendig?
Ja, 987654.
0190-987654, das ist leicht zu merken.
Jetzt nicht sofort wählen, man sollte schon auf dem Alexanderplatz stehen.
Ihr könnt das auch gerne anrufen, das läuft nämlich alles in unserer Spendenkasse und damit finanzieren wir die ganze Aktion.
Aber das sieht wirklich sehr geil aus.
Und die Infos, die wir auch sagen, unter www.ccc.de-blinkenlights findet man auch alle anderen Informationen, auch die ganzen Tools, um damit die Filme zu erstellen. Unter anderem Blinkenpaint, aber auch andere Dinge, wo man wirklich sehr schön das Haus sieht und dann die einzelnen Fenster an- und ausknipsen kann. Achso, und ein weiteres Feature, was wirklich sehr beliebt ist, bei Liebespaaren gerade, man kann halt seine eigenen kleinen Liebesschwüre oder Grüße einstellen, einschicken, unter einem bestimmten Codewort und wenn man dann mit seiner Liebsten davor steht, diese dann heimlich in der Tasche abrufen und dann kommt halt eben auf dem Haus das, was man sich eben überlegt hat. Das ist natürlich auch...
Und ist das abgelaufen und dann sagt Schatz, wo denn, was meinst du denn jetzt? Und dann ist die Scheiße schon gelaufen und dann muss man sich echt was überlegen.
Dann kann man es nochmal abrufen. Und es läuft so lange, wie die Verbindung steht.
Also ich muss sagen, es ist abgesehen davon, dass es nicht so hochauflösend ist, passieren schon einige Sachen, die wirklich geil aussehen, wie zum Beispiel ein Fisch, mit dem man wirklich als Fisch erkennt, der sozusagen so schwimmt und sich so langsam bewegt. Also es ist wirklich geil. Das Schönste ist diese Fliege. Die Fliege find ich toll. Die immer so hängenbleiben.
Also es ist auch... Also es kommen... Tim wird des Ansturms an Filmen irgendwie kaum noch her.
Wir werden einen Wettbewerb machen.
Ja, also es gibt auch einen Wettbewerb mit den Filmen nach verschiedensten Kategorien. Ich hab jetzt schon gesehen, jetzt wo Weihnachten langsam näher rückt, sind auch so die ersten netten Weihnachtspots zu sehen. Zum Beispiel hab ich heute gesehen irgendwie die Adventsgeschichte so auf Blinken, wieder halt so die drei Heiligen so ins Morgenland so trüptüptüpt auf und das auf der Pixelwand. Das ist wirklich abgefahren.
Das ist echt cool. Die Toten Hosen haben da auch ein Video schon gedreht mit viel Spaß dabei. Und was war noch? Eine Demo war, die davor dann auch bespielt wurde. Entsprechend waren einige Sachen. Das ist auch häufiger schon in der Presse gekommen.
Aber es ist jedenfalls ein großer Spaß. Und wer Lust hat, wie gesagt www.wcccde.de Laufen wird das noch wahrscheinlich bis Februar.
Irgendwann wird an diesem Haus auch mal gebaut. Dann werden wir es wohl zurückgeben müssen. Aber bis dahin kann man noch ein bisschen Spaß damit haben. Jetzt zurück zum Thema.
Für die letzten fünf Minuten natürlich. Das lohnt sich. Wir haben am Telefon noch den Thomas. Thomas, bist du noch dran? Es geht um Biometrie. Wir kommen von Blinkenleitz, übrigens eine deutsch-englische Wortkombination. Zurück zum Thema Biometrie. Ist Thomas gleich Tom? Leider nicht. Aber auch deine Aussage, wenn nichts zu verbergen hat, hat nichts zu befürchten, könnte auch vom Landeskriminalamt sein.
Ja, das mag gut sein. Aber es ist eben einfach eine Sache. Ich meine einfach, wenn man sich ein klein wenig an Recht und Ordnung in diesem Lande hält, wie man das eigentlich überall tun sollte, sollte man sich nicht wirklich so darauf versteißen, zu sagen, wenn jetzt irgendjemand Daten von mir bekommt, dann kann er sonst was damit anfangen. Einfach ein kleines Beispiel, ich weiß nicht, mir wird das Auto geklaut, ich sitze da, habe keins mehr, bin dann wahrscheinlich sehr unglücklich darüber und werde ganz sicher nach dem heutigen Stand der Informationen über die Bürger hier gesammelt sind, damit rechnen müssen, dass mein Auto nicht wiedergefunden wird, gibt es eine Datei, in der Fingerabbrücke zum Beispiel flächendeckend gespeichert sind, dürfte das Problem sich damit ganz ganz schnell gelöst haben.
Aber du meinst also auch Fingerabdrücke von ich sag mal allen Italienern, Schweizer, Spanier, Polen, Afghanen, Afrikanern?
Ja, Afghanen, ich will ja auch. Es geht jetzt nicht um Fingerabdrücke weltweit zusammen, weil ich werde mit meinem kleinen Auto wahrscheinlich nicht etwas nach Afghanistan machen.
Nein, aber kennst du nicht den Witz mit den Russen? Warum klauen die Russen immer zwei Autos? Na, die müssen vorher durch Polen. Das Problem ist doch an der Geschichte, dass es überhaupt nicht so sein muss, dass ausgerechnet ein Deutscher dein Auto geklaut hat. Ich will nicht sagen, dass die Deutschen weniger oder mehr kriminell sind, aber du triffst damit einfach mal nur 0, wie viel Prozent der Weltbevölkerung.
Es ist einfach eine Sache. Sicherlich ist es so, dass es nicht sein muss, dass mir ein hier in Deutschland gemeldeter Mensch das Auto klauen muss. Aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass er es tut, ist wesentlich höher, als dass es ein Afghaner tut.
Aber was nützen dir dann die Fingerabdrücke? Ist das eigentlich schon ein implantiertes Handy eigentlich?
Aber wie denn? Die Fingerabdrücke sind am Auto und das ist weg. Wo hast du denn jetzt einen Fingerabdruck? Das musst du erklären. Also da kommt einer mit dem Schraubenzieher, haut das Schloss auf, knack, bumm, macht das Lenkrad Schloss auf, überall am ganzen Auto Fingerabdrücke. Aber das Auto ist weg. Wie willst du denn jetzt den habhaft werden? Die ganzen schönen Fingerabdrücke.
Die haben mir das Haus, das wir gebrochen haben, in meine Einrichtung geklaut.
Okay, hat er Handschuhe an und jetzt?
Ja, hat er Handschuhe an, dann habe ich halt ein Problem.
Ja, natürlich. Nein, wenn du flächendeckend Fingerabdrücke scannst, dann werden die alle immer Handschuhe anhaben. Immer. Werden ja blöde, wenn nicht.
Na, dann werden Handschuhe halt verboten.
Warum werden denn Leute jetzt noch überführt anhand der Fingerabdrücke?
Weißt du, das größte Problem an... Ja, es gibt natürlich immer Bescheuerte, aber die meisten Leute werden halt vielleicht nicht überführt. Deswegen versuchen sie herauszufinden mit Speichel, mit Haarproben und so weiter, weil Fingerabdruck ist halt echt nicht mehr. Das ist nur noch für so Gelegenheitsdelikte, aber irgendjemand mit einer gewissen kriminellen Energie, der wird heute wahrscheinlich schon mit einem Haartuch kommen und sonst was, damit er nicht so viel Zeug liegen lässt. Weißt du, du hast vielleicht sogar recht, aber der viel wichtigere Aspekt ist, du sagst, der unbescholtene Bürger hat doch nicht zu fürchten. Und ich sage nein, falsch. Der unbescholtene Bürger hat zu fürchten, dass jemand anders sich für ihn ausgibt. Wenn diese Merkmale relevant sind, plötzlich. Dann kommen die Bullen zu dir und räumen dich weg, weil du ein Auto geklaut hast, obwohl du es gar nicht war, weil sich jemand für dich ausgegeben hat.
Ich hab schon gesagt, man muss sich dafür hüten, auf irgendwelchen elektronischen Teilen zu unterschreiben. Kriegst du keine Pakete von UPS zum Beispiel? Da unterschreibst du jedes Mal auf so einem Teil.
Die haben keine Beschleunigungssensor. Das ist einfach nur ein Bild der Unterschrift.
Da ist deine Unterschrift gespeichert irgendwo und die liegt da woanders in der Schweite.
Das finden wir nicht gut.
Ich kann auch nicht dem UPS-Fahrer vorwerfen. Ihr sagt, ihr habt kein Vertrauen zum Staat, weil der Staat kein Vertrauen zu euch hat. Ihr habt überhaupt kein Vertrauen zu niemandem.
Nein, das ist jetzt...
Der Typ, der meine Unterschriften aufnimmt, der ist doch nicht zwangsläufig ein superkrimineller Mensch.
Das haben wir nicht gesagt.
Nö, aber was ist mit dem superkriminellen Menschen, der eine Sicherheitslücke im Rechnersystem von UPS gefunden hat, sich mal eben sämtliche Unterschriften aller Leute, die jemals ein UPS-Paket angenommen haben, runterlädt, sich da ein passendes Opfer aussucht, und dann mit der Unterschrift Birzeln einstellt. Das ist doch eine realistische Gefahr, oder nicht?
Das ist keine realistische Gefahr.
Da gab es neulich erst einen Fall, wo eine sechsstellige Anzahl Kreditkartennummern auf einem Web-Server abhandengekommen sind, auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise. Also was ist der Unterschied zwischen Fingerabdrücken und Kreditkartennummern, das handelt sich um Daten, sind Bits, ist es dasselbe, und die Konfigurter sind auch dieselben, auf denen das gespeichert wird.
Ich vergleiche doch einfach mal, da muss man nochmal ein bisschen differenzieren. Ich kann noch nicht, ich müsste mich, das würde nicht mehr ausreichen, wenn ich mich zu Hause einschließe und gar nichts mehr mache. Bloß um irgendwelche Sachen zu entgehen, das ist doch das.
Darum geht es nicht. Es geht darum, dass wir nicht wollen, dass etwas eingeführt wird, was unnötig ist.
Der Punkt ist, es ist teurer Unfug, der da getrieben wird. Wir haben vorhin gehört, dass es auf den meisten Dienststellen an Rechnern mangeln, dass die Beamten alle ohne Ende Überstunden schieben. Und ich glaube, dass wenn man jetzt auch noch, ich sage mal, Milliarden in Biometrie reinsteckt, dann fehlt das Geld an anderen Stellen, wo es einfach viel vernünftiger eingesetzt worden wäre. Und wir misstrauen nicht grundsätzlich dem Staat. Das ist auch zu einfach. Nur, wir haben einfach kein blindes Vertrauen in sämtliche Kontrollmechanismen und insbesondere wissen wir, dass viele Dinge einfach schiefgehen können und dass niemand etwas dagegen tun kann, dass bestimmte Dinge schiefgehen. Und je größer das Risiko ist und so eine Datensammlung, stellt einfach ein großes Risiko dar. Zum Beispiel fürs organisierte Verbrechen. Wenn jemand mehrere Milliarden zur Verfügung hat, die er einsetzen kann, dann wird es für ihn kein generelles Hindernis sein, in den Besitz dieser Daten zu kommen, diese Daten zu fälschen oder diese Daten zu manipulieren. Das kann kein Mensch ausschließen. Nur wenn es diese Daten nicht gibt, ist es halt auch nicht möglich.
Also ausschließen kann man gar nichts.
Ja doch, wenn es diese Daten nicht gibt, dann kann man sie nicht zweckentfremden.
Kannst du auf dieser Welt nichts mehr machen?
Das ist nicht der Fall.
Nein, wir kommen wunderbar, ohne die...
Es funktioniert doch super.
Du gibst Daten von dir ab, wenn du dir einen T-Roll brauchst.
Darum geht es nicht.
Du gibst Daten von dir ab, wenn du dich...
D'accord, wir hatten die Sendung um Datenschleimspur und so weiter. Die ist etliche Sendung her. Hier geht es um ein anderes Thema.
Und man kann es vermeiden. Man kann etwas dagegen tun.
Da wir zeitlich in der Brodülie sind, würde ich Thomas an dieser Stelle danken und das als Schlusswort hinnehmen wollen, weil man kann bestimmtes Geld und es sind wirklich fette Beträge einfach besser ausgeben, wenn man zweimal drüber nachdenkt. Und das finde ich auch ein ganz gutes Fazit. Das hatten wir nämlich zwei oder drei Mal in der Sendung schon. Danke dir, Thomas.
Schade, dass solche Leute immer am Schluss anrufen, wenn man eigentlich nicht mehr ausgiebig diskutieren kann. Weil da wird es dann ja eigentlich spannend. Da kommen die Diskussionen raus insofern.
Ich denke, das wird sich als Schleimspur weitertragen bis zum nächsten Chaosradio Blue Moon, der am nächsten Mittwoch im Monat stattfinden wird, wie es üblich ist. Wir haben es jetzt eine Minute vor. Das heißt, wir werden sowieso noch etwas Zeit klauen vom Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf, der jetzt stattfindet, und verabschieden uns alle.
Wir danken uns bei allen Hörern, die so lange ausgehalten haben, vor allem bei denen, die angerufen haben und hier mitdiskutiert haben. Freut uns immer, wenn da qualifizierte Sachen kommen, fand ich heute wieder ausgezeichnet. Tschüss und schlaft schön und feiert noch oder was ihr sonst so tut da draußen.
Ein Gemeinschaftsprogramm von ORB und SFB. Produziert in Babelsberg.